Older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap of Pogchamp, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Cap of Pogchamp, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour he calls me, his doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Pog is Pogchamp, Cap is Cap of Bible thumb.
Twitch emotes.
Cap of Pogchamp, keep a forehead, Bible thumb.
Ja, das ging dann zwei Stunden oder so.
Also mal ein bisschen Musik an hier.
Was ist das?
Wenn das Fridays for Future sieht.
Was zum Teufel macht der dann? Baut der einen Motor oder was? Was gibt das wenn es fertig ist?
Okay, was auch immer, keine Ahnung.
Es kann aber gar kein richtiger Lego Motor in Lego sein.
Das ist ein Motor der aussieht wie ein Motor ohne ein Motor zu sein.
Also sprich ein Motor der angetrieben wird von einem anderen Motor, weil normalerweise treibt der Motor ja selbst was an und wird nicht angetrieben.
Fake exposed.
Ich habe übrigens noch ein neues Emote rein gemacht.
Easy.
Corona beim Baden, Alter die Leute haben echt Probleme.
Wie gefährlich bestimmte Tätigkeiten sind, um dich anzustecken. Im Prinzip ist es doch ganz einfach. Greifst du irgendwo rein, wo andere Leute dran gegriffen haben und fuddelst dir dann im Gesicht rum, ist das schlecht.
Ob das jetzt im Schwimmbad ist, ob das irgendwo in der Sauna ist, ob das irgendwo beim Supermarkt ist, im Prinzip ist es doch immer das gleiche.
Und ich würde sagen, im Schwimmbad, ohne das Video jetzt gesehen zu haben, im Schwimmbad, wenn du nicht gerade direkt an den anderen dran liegst und dich anhusten lässt, wird da wohl nicht allzu viel passieren.
Also den Glaub fällt echt kein Programm mehr ein.
Übrigens Leute, ich habe mir was überlegt. Achtung Aluhutverschwörungstheorie.
Ich gucke keinen Fernseher. Also ihr wisst ja, ich gucke eigentlich nichts, was es im Fernsehen gibt.
Und meine Mutter guckt ab und zu was. Aber okay, also ich gucke nichts. Und nachdem wir ein Haushalt sind, müssen wir Haushaltsabgabe bezahlen. Das heißt, ich habe gar keine Chance irgendwie, um, das heißt ja nicht mehr GEZ, Rundfunkgebühr, was immer, rumzukommen.
Aber ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen von jemand, der gesagt hat, womit man die richtig ärgern kann, wäre, wenn man seinen Lastschriftauftrag kündigt. Also sprich, wenn man sagt, ja ich bezahle das.
Mal kurz die Musik ticken, leiser.
Ähm, das war es sich jetzt nicht. Achso, ich habe das falsche leiser gemacht.
Genau, also ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt, da hat einer erzählt, okay, man kommt nicht drum herum, den Kram zu bezahlen, sondern die meisten Leute würden wohl per Lastschrift bezahlen.
Und das Beste, was man machen kann, ist, um die zu ärgern, wenn man irgendwie halt dagegen protestieren will, obwohl man ja eigentlich nichts dagegen machen kann, ist sein Lastschrift-Einzug oder sein automatisches Geldbezahlen einzustellen.
Und den zu schreiben, selbstverständlich bezahlst du, wo sollst du es denn hinbringen?
Und das soll die wohl echt in Bedrängnis bringen, insofern, weil sie halt erstens nicht wollen, dass die Leute quasi Geld bezahlen, manche gehen dann so weit und sagen, sie wollen sogar bar bezahlen.
Weil die Frage ist, müssen die das nicht annehmen? Ich meine, du willst ja bezahlen, die nehmen es halt nicht an. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu schon irgendwelche Urteile gibt.
Aber eigentlich klingt es logisch, wenn du sagst, ich möchte bezahlen, wo darf ich denn bezahlen und die geben dir nichts, dann nehmen sie es ja nicht an und dann können sie ja nichts machen.
Und das würde die wohl angeblich echt in Bedrängnis bringen, hat er in dem Video erzählt, weil das halt ein riesen Verwaltungsaufwand für die wäre, wenn sie das machen würden.
Und sie halt, und das ist wohl das Schlimmste für die, weil die regelmäßig in Einnahmen wegfallen.
Klang eigentlich recht big brain, nachdem ich eh kein Fernsehen gucke, mir teilweise die Berichterstattung im Fernsehen übelst auf den Sack geht und ich es nicht einsehe, irgendwie bezahlen zu müssen für den ganzen Kack, den ich eh nicht benutze, finde ich die Idee gar nicht so verkehrt.
Vor allem, wenn du die anguckst, wie die da teilweise vorgehen, da gab es auch vor zwei Jahren oder so, die eine Mutter diese in Beugehaft nehmen wollten oder haben, weil sie es nicht bezahlt hat.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, auf der einen Seite, wenn du wirklich was anstellst, nicht so wild, aber wen du bezahlst, dein Rundfunkgebühr nicht.
Naja, die Nintendo Music ist aber gerade nicht so relaxing.
Ah, das schon eher.
Ah, exzellent.
You suck at cooking, ja.
Früher konnte ich mal halbwegs, zumindest ein paar Sachen, dass ich nicht verhungern musste, aber mittlerweile easy-liefer-service, easy-live.
Was? Ja, kann man gut vorstellen. Also, die GEZ habe ich nie bezahlt, da weiß ich noch, da kam mal in der alten Wohnung, wo ich noch in der alten Wohnung gewohnt habe, kam mal so ein Typ vom hessischen Rundfunk, als ich, ne ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden, das legt sich wahrscheinlich wieder.
Also, als ich noch in der alten Wohnung gewohnt habe, da kam dann, damals als die Ausbildung angefangen habe, da kam dann drei Monate später oder so, nachdem ich angefangen habe, kam irgend so ein Typ vom hessischen Rundfunk rum.
Da hatte ich gemeint, da, ja, sie wissen doch, bestimmt, sie müssen jetzt bezahlen. Ich habe gesagt, ne, Tür zugemacht.
Sagt ihr euch, nie wieder was von dem gehört.
So, aber jetzt, nachdem wir hier im Haus wohnen und einen Haushalt haben und Haushaltsabgabe und sowas, jetzt kommen wir nicht mehr drum herum.
Was die noch mehr abfuckt ist, wenn man 1 Cent mehr überweist. Echt jetzt?
Ja, am besten ist doch, wenn man bar bezahlt.
Ach, Seishin, genau, ja.
Das zum Teufel ist Haste Bin.
Haste Bin, Haste Pin.
Ach, da.
Das ist ja fast das, was ich auch, also relativ ähnlich zu den gleichen Interfaces und Funktionen, die ich da auch hatte.
Nur ein bisschen schöner das Ganze gekapselt.
Oh, das ist cool. Set Volume Absolute, Set Volume Relative, Get Master Volume durch Level.
Okay, was ich cool finde, du machst fast genau das Gleiche, wie ich auch gemacht habe.
Das heißt, wenn wir zu zweit unabhängig schon mal zur gleichen Funktionsweise irgendwie da gekommen sind, da kann das nicht so verkehrt sein.
Leider, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch mitgekriegt hast, Seishin, leider funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Also, das Volume ändern funktioniert schon, aber Modern Warfare erkennt das Programm, was die Audio-Lautstärke ändert als Cheat und beendet sich.
Leider funktioniert das Kram nicht.
Man könnte das jetzt irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr verschleiern, ja, aber ich mal scheiß drauf.
Ja, das erkennt das als Cheat.
Ist halt Fail.
Ich vermute mal, es erkennt es als Cheat, weil ich im Hintergrund nach Prozessen suche, die Modern Warfare heißen.
Und das heißt, ich müsste das jetzt ein bisschen verschleiern, alles.
Aber ja.
Wie in den Battlefield 1 Trailer.
Die Dera 505, na, virtualisierte Sachen. Ich würde sagen, es ist ähnlich, wie wenn du Sachen mit Wine unter Linux spielst.
Die schlagen halt gerne an. Gut, warum es natürlich voll virtualisiert anschlägt, verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Vielleicht haben sie Schiss, dass die Leute dadurch mehr Sachen manipulieren oder so, man weiß es nicht.
So, ich würde sagen, wir fangen mit einer Runde Battlefield an.
Ja, wir fangen mal mit einer Runde Battlefield an.
Da kann ich mich erst noch ein bisschen aufwachen, aber das ist ja auch Sinn und Zweck des Streams.
Das Commentary müssen wir eh nicht großartig ändern, weil er sagt immer genau das Gleiche.
Was, wenn du rechtsklick auf Chromium machst, wieder rechtsklick auf Chromium machst,
dann Eigenschaften und an Force Dark Mode dranhängen, geht das der Browser auch im Dark Mode?
Doch, ich glaube, das geht.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, wo ich klicken muss.
Wo muss ich denn klicken?
Ach, du meinst hier unten, du meinst das hier, wo du sagen kannst, Settings.
Ja, doch, ich glaube, das funktioniert. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, ich will jetzt nicht neu starten.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es funktioniert, ich glaube sogar, dass wir es schon mal ausprobiert haben.
Ich muss übrigens auch mein Frageboard starten, sonst übersehe ich wieder die Hälfte.
Ach, Shidera, so ist das. Ja, das ist Fail.
Ja, das habe ich mal gemacht. Bei irgendeinem, also 2011 oder so, bei irgendeinem Call of Duty habe ich auch mal von der Xbox den Traffic mitgelesen.
Der war zwar verschlüsselt, aber es ging damals um die Frage, wie viel Bandbreite so Call of Duty Multiplayer Traffic verbraucht.
Ich habe ja schon immer behauptet, das verbraucht quasi nichts und die Leute haben es mir nicht geglaubt.
Da habe ich es mal mitgeschnitten und das hat halt nichts verbraucht.
Nächste Woche stellt EA die neuen Spiele für Next-Gen vor. Was meinst du? Vielleicht was Spannendes.
Wann denn? Ist das ein Livestream, den wir uns angucken können? Darf man das restreamen? Wo gibt es das?
Oder ist das einfach nur irgend so ein komischer EA Marketing Post?
Wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal, also EA. EA Presentation Next-Gen Games.
Ist das hier Digital Gaming?
Was da?
Das war schon.
Wo ist das denn?
Vielleicht logge ich mich später mal.
Ach hier.
Okay. EA Play Event.
4 PM PT. So gibt es das vielleicht?
Was? 1 Uhr nachts? Ist das denn hier ernst?
Moment haben wir schon CESC oder haben wir CET?
Eine E3 Konfig. Excellent.
Ich hoffe, wir haben schon Sommerzeit, oder?
Aber 1 Uhr, das ist ja scheiß Zeit.
Also wir könnten da streamen, weil ich mein, Montag habe ich frei.
Wie lange geht das denn?
Das schaffen sie ja, Sommer.
Haben die nicht letztens vor 2 Jahren oder so eine Umfrage gemacht,
ob man nicht Sommer-Winterzeit-Umstellung abschalten will?
Und da haben irgendwie 90% der Leute gesagt ja.
Und wo ist es jetzt? Warum gibt es das immer noch?
Es gab doch ne Umfrage.
Abschaffen Sommerzeit-Umfrage, gab es doch?
Hier 80% der Teilnehmer, wann war das?
2018, warum gibt es das immer noch?
Warum gibt es das immer noch, wenn 80% der Teilnehmer das abstellen wollen?
Ich mein, 2 Jahre sollte doch reichen, so was zu streichen, oder?
Okay, wir machen uns mal kurz nen Termin. Events.
Also wir haben einmal EA Play Live haben wir.
Dann was, wann ist Apple? 22. Apple, was ist denn das für eine?
Apple?
Dann können wir uns die Keynote angucken.
Wie viel Uhr?
Jetzt weiß ich auch, was die ganzen Leute immer auf Twitter für Avatare haben.
Jetzt check ich das auch. Das ist irgendein Apple-Ding.
Ich hab auf Twitter Leute gesehen mit Avataren, die sehen so ähnlich aus wie diese hier.
Das scheint irgendein Apple-Ding zu sein.
Ich hab mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, was ist das?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo Kronk früher, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Kronk immer noch dieses gleiche Bild hat.
Avatar-Bild.
Ja, Kronk hat doch früher schon immer dieses Daumen-Hoch-Bild gehabt.
Und jeder, jeder Let's-Player zur damaligen Zeit, jeder Let's-Player hat so nen Daumen-Hoch-Bild gemacht.
Und jetzt macht sich jeder Apple-Fan irgendwie so ein komisches Avatar-Ding.
True, lol.
Ok, wann geht's denn los, Apple?
Keynote.
1 PM ET.
1 PM ET, true.
Zeitzone.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal gut.
Kommen wir mal hier rauf.
Apple-Keynote.
1 PM ET.
Wir schreiben auch gleich noch dabei.
19 Uhr, 19 Uhr Sonntag.
Das ist doch gut.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch das Datum dabei schreiben.
22.
Warte mal, Juni?
Juli?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass nicht nur die Kokona-Einheiten-Kacke wären, sondern auch die Monatsbezeichnungen sind so, dass ich sie mir nicht merken kann.
Ich glaube, Juni ist das, ne?
Kokona-Monate und Einheiten.
So, haben wir das doch mal aufgeschrieben.
Also das hier ist 1 Uhr Nacht.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen spät, aber die Keynote von Apple können wir uns angucken.
Dann ist erstmal Tim...
Wie heißt der?
Tim Cook?
Tom Cook?
Tim, oder?
Tim.
Nicht Tom.
Fast.
KappaPride.
Eine Webseite für so einen Eventkalender wäre doch mal...
Ah ja, das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Siehst du, heute ist wieder Absolute Big Brain angesagt.
Kalender für Events, die uns im Stream angucken.
Ich könnte einfach einen Google-Kalender freigeben, aber wir basteln lieber sowas selbst.
Das ist viel besser.
So, also jetzt gucken wir uns ein bisschen Battlefield an.
Wo war's?
Da, ich hab's gesehen.
Highly Wahnsinns Reaction Times gerade.
Also, incredible Rambo Moments.
Okay, ich erwarte wieder jede Menge Braindead-Gegner, die absolut gar nichts checken.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das Savote?
Savote.
Ich glaub schon.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wie trifft der überhaupt was?
Der trifft die Gegner doch gar nicht.
Kommt mal hier.
What the fuck?
Wollt ihr mich verabbeln?
Okay, den hat er getroffen.
Was?
Naja, okay, der hat ein bisschen spät gehitreckt, den einen.
Aber trotzdem, das waren echt mega glückliche Hits gerade.
Ja, das ist okay.
Das passt auch alles.
Aber am Anfang war irgendwie merkwürdig.
Gestern hatten wir den übelst krassen Cheater in Warzone.
Der hat gespielt Schild und Armbrust.
Also, ein typisches Warzone-Layout.
Wer kennt's nicht?
Schild und Armbrust.
Und hat damit across map gereckt.
Ich hab mich ja auch gewundert, wie das geht.
Weil Armbrust ist ja eigentlich projektiv, dachte ich.
Aber es ging ohne Probleme.
Ich mach das absichtlich nicht so laut, weil das commentary immer das gleiche ist, was der erzählt.
Es gibt Gerüchte, dass Battlefield 3 Remastered werden soll.
Ja, den bleibt ja nix anderes da übrig.
Die müssen ja irgendwas rausbringen zur Überbrückung für Battlefield 6.
Ich mein, man muss mir ehrlich sagen, Battlefield 3 braucht absolut keinen Remastered.
Battlefield 3, wisst ihr was reichen würde, ganz ehrlich?
Wenn die jetzt in Battlefield 3 DLC rausbringen würden, die Server wären wieder voll.
Weil Battlefield 3 muss nicht Remastered werden, Battlefield 3 könnten sie einfach ein bisschen überarbeiten in neue Patches.
Wenn die jetzt wieder Support aufnehmen würden für Battlefield 3 und 4,
dann sagen wir mal, lassen wir mal Battlefield 3 weg.
Nehmen wir mal Battlefield 4, weil Battlefield 4 ja schon die bisschen neuere und umfangreichere Game ist.
Wenn die jetzt sagen würden, okay, wir nehmen wieder Support für Battlefield 4 auf,
bringen vielleicht noch ein paar Battlefield 3 Maps. Ich mein, wie geil wäre es, wenn man Demoman Peak in Battlefield 4 spielen könnte.
Wenn die wieder den Support aufnehmen würden für Battlefield 4, die Server wären wieder knagevoll.
Die Server sind jetzt auch halbwegs gut besucht noch.
Die Hexa hat letztens gesagt, es wären teilweise Battlefield 4 nicht mal richtig spielbar.
Es wäre sofort wieder die Leute am Start, gar keine Frage.
Die Leute wollen bloß kein altes Battlefield ohne Support spielen, weil es ja auch ein bisschen den Reiz verliert,
wenn es immer exakt das gleiche ist und alle Sachen, die dir auf den Sack gehen, du sicher sein kannst, die werden nie wieder gefixt.
Aber natürlich ist Battlefield 3 Remastered die bessere Variante, um Geld zu verdienen.
Da kann man nämlich einfach nichts machen, weil man muss an Battlefield 3 mit Sicherheit nicht allzu viel remasteren.
Und dann ist es wieder am Start.
Besser wäre, sie würden endlich aus Battlefield 4 ein Service Game machen.
Stellt euch mal vor, wie geil das wäre. Sie würden ein richtig großes Battlefield 4 Update machen,
was quasi mehr oder weniger noch Sachen aus Battlefield 3 integriert, sprich die guten Rush Maps und nicht diesen Crap, wie es in Battlefield 4 gab.
Die würden ein richtig großes Rush oder generell ein richtig großes Content Update noch mal machen für Battlefield 4
und sagen, okay, wir bauen das jetzt um auf ein Service Game.
Das wäre ein Service Game, das würde ich sogar spielen.
Die würde ich noch nicht mal flamen dafür. Das würde ich sogar spielen. Den würde ich sogar Geld ausgeben.
Ich würde es sogar nochmal kaufen oder, Mörder, ich wollte es gerade sagen, oder sie sind richtig big brain.
Sie machen das free to play mit irgendeiner sinnvollen Monetarisierung.
Stellt euch mal vor, ein Service Game ist einfach ein Game, was über längere Zeit mit Content versorgt wird und geupdatet wird
und permanent dem Entwickler auch Kohle bringt, um es mal so unterm Strich zu sagen.
Also stellt euch mal vor, die würden das wirklich free to play machen.
Man könnte sogar sagen, Base Game ist free to play und das neueste Content Update, irgendwas.
Da sollten sie sich irgendwas ausdenken. CSGO ist quasi ein Service Game, ja.
Oh, das war noch vor einer Zeit, wo man das noch nicht Service Game genannt hat.
Jedes MMO ist ein Service Game.
Also was, was permanent Income bringt für den Entwickler und auch für die Spieler permanent Content.
Einfach ein Spiel, was über lange Zeit supportet wird.
Wenn sie das machen würden, ich glaube, dann wäre Battlefield 4 über Nacht das meistgespielte Battlefield,
was ja auch keine große Kunst ist gerade, das meistgespielte Battlefield und das würde wieder richtig viele Leute dazu bringen, das Game zu spielen.
Das wäre geil, oder? Aber das werden sie nicht machen.
Das könnte so einfach sein.
Noshark Hennels TDM, was sonst?
Diese kack Pose, da würde ich aus Prinzip keinen Clip zeigen.
Das ist die reudigste Pose im ganzen Spiel.
Na gut, er geht wenigstens runter, dann ist okay, dann kann man es zeigen.
Die Gegner sind mal wieder absupprained.
Oh, beste Waffe, beste Waffe, MP4, Rex, Rex, beste, beste Revolver.
Auf der Konsole braucht es ein Remaster, naja, die müssen das einfach mal rausbringen für die aktuellen Konsolen ordentlich.
Da müssen die, glaube ich, gar nicht allzu viel machen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich fast out of the box laufen auf einer PS4 flüssig.
Null.
Was ist mit dem los? Was ist mit dem Dude hier los?
Machen die einmal Kreisel-Sniper oder was?
Was ist da los? What the fuck?
Oh.
Hä, an was, Moment, an was ist der eine Gegner eben gestorben, das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
What the fuck, Moment.
Die zwei sind klar und der jetzt? Der hat doch gar nicht getroffen.
An was ist der Gegner jetzt genau gestorben?
Okay, das ist, glaube ich, entweder Hyping oder Battlefield-Hit-Rack-Geschichten, oder ein anderer, oder ein anderer Spieler hat ihn gekillt.
Ja, oder hatte Corona, ja.
Was verstehe ich jetzt, dass die umkippen? War One-Hit.
Ja, aber laut Lebensbalken nicht.
Aber da muss ich, darf man sich in Battlefield eh nicht so sehr drauf verlassen.
Aber ich habe übelst Bock, Battlefield, ich würde ja gerne mal wieder eine Runde Bad Company 2 spielen.
Um zu gucken, ob das Game, wow, der war cool, ob das Game noch lebt.
Sind die alle da gespawnt gerade?
Das kommt vor, das kommt, dass diese Momente gab es. Ja, das kommt vor.
Was ist denn das für eine Waffe?
Habe ich nie verwendet. Crap-Waffe. Und dann auch noch den Single-Schuss.
Okay, das ist jemand, der gimpt sich im Waffenlayout gerne selbst, aber es funktioniert.
Bisschen eine Runde Rätts drehen, beste.
Low Settings, beste. Ich habe Battlefield 3 heute noch immer auf Low Settings, weil Max FPS.
Okay, das war schlecht. Und vor allem, man sieht Gegner teilweise besser.
Man sieht manchmal Gegner, wenn ihr im Tunnel liegt, in Demavent Peak im Tunnel, dann sind ja Kisten.
Und wenn ihr die Settings auf Low habt, sieht ihr die Gegner, aber die Kisten werden nicht gereinert, weil sie zu weit weg sind.
Eigentlich hätte ich damals ein Video darüber machen müssen, so nach dem Motto, Pro Gamer Leaks Incredible Battlefield 3 Hack oder sowas.
Exposed, Exposed, Pro Gamer Leaks Incredible Battlefield Hack.
Der wird garantiert geflammt danach. Shotgun-Spieler werden immer geflammt mit Battlefield.
Erstmal kurz die Werbung überspringen.
Ja, Luns Haruno, da hätten wir alle Bock drauf, glaube ich.
Shingekuru hoch so lang schon 11 Monate, exzellent Subscription.
IQ steigt. Ich merke es dem Chat schon richtig an.
M16.
Ja, beste Waffe im ganzen Spiel.
Renax, ja, ich habe es gestern gespielt. Modern Warfare ist der Multiplayer gerade kostenlos.
Das heißt, eigentlich sollte die Welt voller Noob-Lobby sein, aber man sieht anhand skill-based matchmaking keine Noobs, was natürlich nicht existiert laut Hersteller.
Skill-based matchmaking gibt es natürlich nicht.
Der Multiplayer, was man da auch wieder sieht, ist dermaßen schlecht. Ich glaube nicht, dass es für Verkaufszahlen sorgt.
Der Modern Warfare Multiplayer ist das schlechteste Call of Duty Multiplayer aller Zeiten.
Ich dachte am Anfang, ja, es liegt nur an Maps, aber es liegt an allem.
An einem kompletten Flow, wie das Gameplay sich anfühlt, der Multiplayer ist dermaßen scheiße.
Warzone hat das Game komplett gerettet. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich spiele relativ viel Warzone.
Warzone macht Spaß, aber Warzone ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie die Offenbarung oder so.
Das ist so quasi der letzte Grashalm an dem Game, der funktioniert. Der Rest ist einfach kacke.
Die Kampagne ist okay, aber auch jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn.
Dann sollen sie lieber ein ordentliches Battlefield machen, was keinen Sinn ergibt, weil das noch nie die gleichen Entwickler waren.
Ein ordentliches Battlefield, da würde ich mich echt richtig drüber freuen.
Für Black Ops 5 oder wie es auch immer heißen mag, mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen die wieder einen ordentlichen Multiplayer hin.
Aber wo ich echt lange schon drauf warte, ein ordentliches Battlefield. Ich muss überlegen, das letzte Battlefield ist 5 Jahre her.
Hast du schon gehört, bei Destiny 2 wurde letzte Woche das Skill-Based Matchbacking rausgenommen? Nee, hab ich nicht gehört.
Cold War heißt das neue Konter. Ich weiß nicht, ob das offiziell ist. Es gab jetzt Gerüchte, es würde Cold War heißen.
Es gab Gerüchte, es würde einfach nur Black Ops heißen. Man weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, Bad Company 3 sind es zu unfähig für mittlerweile.
Damals konnte man auch richtig rein suchen. Ja, das stimmt.
Es geht, also wir spielen ja gerade auch relativ viel Warzone, aber das ist kein Spiel, wo ich mir wirklich vorstellen könnte,
das für ein Jahr zu spielen oder so. Das kann ich jetzt zwei, drei Monate spielen, weil es halt echt nichts anderes gibt.
Vielleicht kommt da die neue Path of Exile League raus, die mir wieder Spaß macht.
Aber so ein Spiel, wo ich quasi ein Jahr durchspiele wie in Battlefield 3 und immer noch quasi permanent was entdecke,
was ich anders machen kann und was es noch für Aspekte in dem Spiel gibt, was ich noch nicht gemacht hab.
Obwohl es halt ein Spiel ist, was keinen so extremen Support dauerhaft gekriegt hat, bis auf ein paar neue Maps und so ein paar Waffen.
Ist schon geil und eigentlich ein Spiel, was man permanent spielen will.
Oder checken die Gegner viel zu laut oder checken die Gegner mal wieder gar nichts.
Wichtige PP-Ga-Aimer. Moment, hab ich eigentlich einen PP-Ga-Aim? Emote? PP-Ga-Aim-Emote brauchen wir noch.
Wichtig. Excellent. Save As. PP-Ga-Aim. Das ist wichtig, das brauchen wir noch. Ohne geht hier nichts.
Jawoll. Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt haben wir die passenden Emotes am Start dafür.
Boah, die lassen sich aber richtig gut wegsprayen.
Aber die Waffe ist auch so krass OP. Ich mein, das Ding hatte zwar Recoil, aber der Recoil war einfach nur so.
Einfach nur so. So war der Recoil. Du konntest einfach ein bisschen nach unten ziehen und schon ist das Ding exakt an Point geblieben.
Doch, ich hab mein Mikro gewechselt. Aber wenn man ordentliche Mikros hat, hören sie sich halt ordentlich an.
War das Close Quarters? Ach Quatsch, nee, das ist Battlefield 4. Patchy Necky. Ich glaub nicht, dass man jetzt Patchy Necky ausspricht.
Das ist bestimmt russisch und ich kann russisch nicht aussprechen.
Ist doch Battlefield 3, oder? Ja, der blaue Stich. Ist doch Close Quarters, ja, dann hab ich's richtig in Erinnerung gehabt.
Ich find's ja cool, dass es da noch Server gibt. Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Wisst ihr was das Schöne war? Auch an so chaotischen Sachen wie Noshark, Candles, TDM. Es war nicht so extrem random.
Guckt euch den Modern Warfare Multiplayer an. Es ist einfach random as fuck. Du kannst aus 20 Winkeln abgeaimt werden.
Dazu gibt es noch 20 Sachen, die dich random einfach across the map killen können.
Dann gibt es noch Killstreaks, die dich random across the map killen können. Komplett für'n Arsch, ja.
So ist das wunderbar. Das ist einfach zweckmäßig, ja. Run, Gun, Fetisch.
Der Ingame Chat, was hab ich verpasst? Was hab ich im Ingame Chat verpasst?
Wo ist der Chat? Ach, da oben.
Das passt eigentlich ganz gut gerade.
Am Anfang hatten die ja die Lichter in Battlefield 3 so hell, dass du in der Metro nichts gesehen hast.
Oh, ob ich die Map jemals gespielt hab? Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Bestimmt, bestimmt. Doch, doch, klar, klar. Ich glaube, die Map hat mir nicht so gut gefallen in dem Spiel.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dran.
Erstmal schön Spawn-Rape.
Oh, Granate rein. Der hat doch noch eine Granate.
Der hat als erstes die Granate werfen müssen und dann reinballern, dass sie nicht mehr durchblicken.
Aber die Gegner sind ja auch massiv pepega.
Guckt euch die Gegner an, die sind so unglaublich dämlich.
Tobi, da hast du recht.
Da kann man nicht drüber springen.
Okay, Basar, Metro, Metro, Basar. Vielleicht kriegen wir heute noch Close Quarters Maps. Vielleicht gibt es heute noch normale Maps.
So ein ordentliches Dämmerwändepieck.
Gameplay hätte noch mal was.
Ich kriege Maps.
Hä? Moment, über was ist der da? Ist der gerade über den Gegner drüber gesprungen oder steht da stand da eine Tonne?
Steht da eine Tonne? Da steht normalerweise eine Tonne, oder?
Der wird nicht über die Gegner drüber gesprungen sein. Über Gegner kann man nicht überspringen.
Okay, Locker, Locker. Ja, Locker gibt es auch öfters.
China Zeichen.
Das war eines der Schwächen auch ein bisschen in Battlefield 3 noch, aber vor allem in Bad Company 2.
In Bad Company 2 kannst du durch Holz und sowas sehr easy durchballern, das Spotting.
Also man muss sagen, wenn du in Bad Company 2 auf Valparaiso, wenn du in Valparaiso in dieser Häusersektion der Map warst, wenn du gespottet warst, du warst tot.
Du konntest nirgends wohin, außer vielleicht hinter den ein oder anderen Steinen, aber du konntest nirgends wohin, du konntest durch die Häuser gebashed werden.
50 Minuten gehighlightet warst, gefühlt.
Ich finde den Valorant Style gar nicht so schlecht mit dem Spotten. Das ist ja nur ganz kurz immer.
Kodra Site, beste.
Was war das denn? Was war das?
Woher kommen die Flammen? Woher kommen die Flammen? Kann mir das mal jemand erklären, das kapier ich nicht.
Woher kommen die Flammen?
Hat irgendjemand, der sagt das so, als wäre das selbstverständlich?
Gasleitungen? Es gab auf Locker Gasleitungen, die man...
Okay. Lull. Wusste ich gar nicht.
Oh Konsolenauflösung. Man sieht das sofort am FOF.
Ohne Scheiß, ich hab mittlerweile das Problem, weil ich ja auch öfters ein bisschen Warzone spiele und ich hab 110er FOF und ab und zu gucke ich halt mal auf Twitch auch ein bisschen Konsolengameplay.
Es wird dir leicht motionsick beim Konsolen FOF. Das liegt nicht am Konsolen FOF, das liegt, weil das Hirn halt drauf eingestellt ist, was für einen Winkel man sieht.
Und wenn man auf einmal so einen Mini-Winkel sieht, hat man das Gefühl, man sieht eigentlich nur so einen kleinen Ausschnitt, denkt man sich im Kopf, aber es passt nicht zusammen, weil es in Wirklichkeit der gesamte Ausschnitt ist und denkst, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
So geht es mir mittlerweile, wenn ich Low FOF sehe.
Aber das ist nur, wenn man halt High FOF gewöhnt ist. Das liegt nicht unbedingt an der Konsole oder so. Gut, ich meine, die Auflösungen der Motionplur machen es jetzt nicht unbedingt besser.
Aber es liegt am FOF.
Als hätte man Scheuerklappen, ja. Also bei mir ist es halt so, mein Hirn denkt, ich sehe nur ein Viertel des Bildschirms. Dabei ist es aber gameplaytechnisch der ganze Bildschirm und das macht meinen Hirn kaputt.
Hä?
Friendly Fire? Ach nee, Farbenplint-Modus. Lull.
Overwatch Low FOF. Ich glaube, Overwatch, weiß ich gar nicht, was ich da für einen FOF hatte, 90 oder so?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was man da einstellen konnte.
Haha, Snackart-TV. Cool Idee. Da muss noch ein bisschen clickbaity sein, der Titel, der reicht noch nicht.
Die G18, die G8. Warum hat er den nicht getroffen? Lull, der Stand, der war direkt drauf.
Oh, die G18, das war auch so ein OP-Ding.
Man erkennt sofort am Movement, dass die Konsole ist.
Das ist aber okay, weil das Problem haben wir alle. Jetzt schreckt.
Die Gegner wieder PP-Geheim. Also nicht er, sondern die.
Aber kurz, ich muss mal meine Emotes ein bisschen verschieben. Ein bisschen kleiner, ein bisschen mehr auf die Seite.
Wow. Die Waffe hat man selten gesehen.
Wisst ihr, wie geil ich auch die Reload-Animations finde in Battlefield? Guckt euch das mal an. Wie weich die Reload-Animation, die Bolt-Action-Animation ist. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich meine, die Animation ist jetzt nicht Big Brain, der macht halt einfach nur Hand Vor, Hand Zurück, Hand Vor, Hand Zurück. Aber, ähm, ja, trotzdem nice.
Smooth as fuck, genau.
Ich wusste, dass irgendwie einer damit jetzt ankommt. Das war mir so klar, dass irgendwer hier dieses Emote auspacken muss.
So.
Ein excellent Video.
Deine Meinung zu Battlefield on Stream? Gut, die Games ändern sich ja dadurch nicht.
Die mussten ja langsam mal. Origin interessiert nach 5 Jahren halt immer noch keinen. Schon die Vector probiert, ja, hab ich schon am Max-Level.
Das war anstrengend, sag ich euch.
Kennst du Rare Secret Battlefield Reload-Animations? Nee.
Also, ein bisschen für die Spielerzahl könnte es was tun, dass es Battlefield auf Steam gibt. Aber der Witz ist ja, im Prinzip ist es immer noch Origin.
Das geht ja durch, das launcht ja nicht über Steam direkt, das launcht ja Origin. Und es ist halt BattleLog und BattleLog hat in modernen Browsern Probleme.
Ok, das gucken wir uns später an. Wir haben genug Battlefield jetzt geguckt. Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Du wurdest gehackt. 10 Anzeichen, die du nicht ignorieren solltest. Ok, Monka Hacker Man.
Battlefield jetzt in Steam erhält... Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Deswegen hab ich das doch gerade erzählt.
Bad Company 2 lief über Steam, ja.
So, was haben wir noch? 3 Tipps für Wahl deiner ersten Programmiersprache. Ok, das gucken wir jetzt.
Mal gucken, ob sich das deckt mit dem, was ich immer empfehle. Also, früher hab ich ja immer gesagt, Ruby ist gut zum Einstieg. Mittlerweile, würde ich sagen, Ruby nicht mal so sehr.
Mittlerweile eindeutig Python anstatt von Ruby. Und dann die Frage, was man machen will.
Also, eigentlich gibt es für mich so die Auswahl, entweder fängt man mit der Kombination aus JavaScript, HTML, CSS an, man fängt mit Python an oder wenn man Windows-Anwendungen machen will, fängt man mit.NET und C-Sharp an.
So, das sind so meine 3 Sachen. Mal gucken, was er erzählt.
Hi Leute, heute werden wir mal darüber sprechen, welche Programmiersprache du als erstes lernen solltest. Viel Spaß.
Exzellent. Bisschen lauter, ne?
Warte mal, bis er anfängt zu reden. Schau dir das Video wahrscheinlich gerade an, weil du gemerkt hast, dass es...
Ich mag Videos nicht, wo Leute mit du angesprochen werden. Das cringet immer so bei mir. Aber es ist geschmacksam.
Weil du gemerkt hast, dass es eine Vielzahl von Programmiersprachen gibt, aber du nirgends eine Information darüber gefunden hast, welche Programmiersprache jetzt die beste ist.
Am besten ist Visual Basic 6.
Der Grund dafür ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Es gibt nicht die beste Programmiersprache, die man für alles benutzen kann.
Richtig.
Jede Programmiersprache hat ihre Daseinsberechtigung, aber es stimmt schon, dass manche Programmiersprachen vielseitiger eingesetzt werden können.
Ja.
Eigentlich wollte ich diese Frage nach der Programmiersprache, die man als erstes lernen soll, dann im Q&A beantworten, aber ich hab dann gemerkt, dass es eigentlich den Rahmen komplett sprengen würde und das ist eigentlich ein ganz eigenes Video.
Das ist mal was, den Rahmen komplett sprengen oder nur ein 7-Minuten-Video. Der kann es echt auf den Punkt bringen.
Wie du dazu brauchst. Deshalb zeige ich euch heute mal drei Faktoren, die euch dabei helfen, eure Programmiersprache zu finden.
Die erste Frage, die ihr euch stellen müsst, was möchtest du entwickeln?
Richtig. Das sage ich auch immer. Genau das ist die richtige Frage, mit der man anfangen soll.
Super viele Kategorien. Ich habe jetzt mal...
Was macht denn das Mikrofon da?
Ja, dafür rausgesucht, die wahrscheinlich für euch am interessantesten sind.
Das erste wären beispielsweise die Apps.
Ja.
Darunter müsst ihr euch natürlich wieder unterscheiden, ob ihr jetzt für Android oder für iOS entwickeln möchtet und jeweils dafür gibt es dann auch wieder verschiedene Sprachen.
Wenn ihr beispielsweise für Android Apps entwickeln möchtet, dann ist natürlich Java oder Kotlin...
Java! Ah!
Und für iOS wäre es...
Wenn schon gleich, Flutter, Cross-Platform, Easy. Da muss man nicht mit dem ganzen Java-Crap unter Android anfangen.
Siehe das WIFT. Natürlich gibt es auch Cross-Platform-Lösungen wie Flutter.
Wer ist denn?
Damit ihr euch dann mit der Programmiersprache Dart auseinandersetzt.
Ein Vorteil von Cross-Platform-Lösungen sind natürlich, dass du eine App schreibst oder also den Code einmal schreibst.
Oder der läuft dann auf Android, iOS...
Also wenn ich heute eine Mobile App machen müsste, dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich mit Flutter machen.
Oder tatsächlich mit irgendwas Richtung Electron, weil...
Also wenn ich rein mobile machen würde, dann würde ich es eindeutig Flutter machen.
Wenn ich irgendwas basteln müsste, was Desktop und mobile ist und ich möchte das in einer Codebase irgendwie abfackeln,
dann würde ich wirklich gucken, dass ich das so weit wie es geht browserbasiert mache.
Warum gefällt es C-Sharp und nicht Java?
Es gibt keinen tieferen Grund, weil mir das Framework besser gefällt auf jeden Fall.
C-Sharp ist sehr viel. Auch Desktop, soweit ich weiß.
Die zweite Kategorie, die wahrscheinlich sehr interessant für euch ist, sind die Videospiele.
Häufig benutzt man Programmiersprachen. Dafür ist einmal C++ oder Java.
Oder wenn ihr das Ganze mit Unity programmieren möchtet, dann müsst ihr natürlich die Programmiersprache C-Sharp benutzen.
Das Gute an Unity ist, dass es super viele Tutorials dafür gibt.
Und für Privatpersonen...
C++, Alter.
Zum Glück, ich glaube, eines der Hauptgründe, warum Unity so extrem erfolgreich ist,
neben dem, dass sie natürlich alles dabei haben, was man irgendwie braucht,
ist, dass sie gesagt haben, wir verwenden C-Sharp.
Haben sie nicht von Anfang an...
Am Anfang hatte Unity, glaube ich, wie ist das...
Ist das Boo? War das Boo in Unity ursprünglich?
Ich glaube, das war die ursprüngliche Sprache von Unity.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht komplett falsch liege...
Boo hat sich nicht durchgesetzt und C-Sharp...
Und das ist für mich auch der riesen Vorteil, was Unity für mich wäre, wenn ich Spiele machen möchte,
was ich nicht mache, dass es in C-Sharp ist.
Weil dieses ganze C++-Geschiss halte ich auf Dauer nicht aus.
Webentwicklung.
Die weitverbreiteste Sprache dafür ist einmal JavaScript.
Und für Privatpersonen ist das Ganze auch kostenlos.
Die dritte Kategorie ist die Webentwicklung.
Die weitverbreiteste Sprache dafür ist einmal JavaScript, weil ihr damit den Backend-Teil,
also den serverseitigen Teil eurer App entwickeln könnt und den Frontend-Teil.
Aber wenn man unbedingt scharf drauf ist, kann man natürlich auch JavaScript auf dem Server verwenden.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe noch nie eine Node.js-Backend gebastelt.
Ich habe mich immer davor gedrückt.
Der Teil eurer Applikation oder Website oder was auch immer, der bei dem Nutzer im Endeffekt an dem Browser läuft.
Zusätzlich zum Frontend, das sind keine Programmiersprachen, aber was ihr auf jeden Fall auch noch können müsst,
sind Dinge wie HTML und CSS.
Ach gut, da kommst du nicht drum herum, das stimmt.
CSS ist dann die Kleidung, also die Styling, die eure Website haben wird.
Und die ganze Funktionalität wird dann mit JavaScript implementiert.
Oder wenn ihr es euch direkt geben möchte, dann könnt ihr auch die vierte Kategorie nehmen,
Data Engineering oder Machine Learning.
Das war in Python sehr weit verbreitet.
Wie ihr gesehen habt, wird es für verschiedene Kategorien auf verschiedene Programmiersprachen.
Deshalb gehen wir jetzt direkt zum zweiten Faktor über und das ist der Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Ich war mal wieder weg, warte mal.
Das ist kein Geheimnis, dass manche Programmiersprachen viel einfacher zu lernen sind als andere.
Ach was, kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Jemand mal hier versucht hat Rust zu lernen.
Rust ist wirklich Big Brain Sprache hoch 10.
Vor allem, wenn man mit der Programmierung bisher noch gar keine Erfahrungen hat.
Wenn wir jetzt das Beispiel nehmen von der App Programmierung,
dann würde ich sagen, dass Kotlin für Android einfach zu lernen ist als Java.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und für iOS, da weiß ich es garantiert, Swift ist viel einfacher zu lernen als Objective-C.
Objective-C ist Monka Kotz.
Das ist ein komplett anderes Thema, deshalb haben wir beidigere Vor- und Nachteile.
Aber es geht jetzt einfach nur um den Schwierigkeitsgrad, wenn man eine neue Sprache lernt.
Wenn wir jetzt mal zur nächsten Kategorie rüber gehen, dem Video spielen,
dann wissen wir, dass C++ eine Sprache ist, die relativ schwer zu erlernen ist im Gegensatz zu C Sharp beispielsweise.
C++ ist unnötig Scheiße einfach nur.
So viel uninkonsistenten Crap, wie es in C++ gibt und wie rückständig C++ an vielen Stellen ist,
macht C++ komplizierter als es sein müsste.
Der dritte Punkt ist natürlich der Arbeitsmarkt.
Wenn du es einfach nur für dich selbst ein bisschen programmieren möchtest, als Hobby,
oder deine eigene Indie-App oder dein Indie-Spiel entwickeln möchtest,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich eher uninteressant für dich.
Also so wie Warzone.
Aber wenn du es wieder vorhast, in einem Berufs-Software-Entwickler zu arbeiten,
dann ist es natürlich wichtig, dass du dich auf gefragte Technologien fokussierst.
Logischerweise sind gefragte Technologien, für die es relativ wenige Entwickler gibt,
aber einen sehr hohen Bedarf, viel besser bezahlt als andere.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es gibt verschiedene Webseiten, die dabei helfen können, eine Übersicht zu bekommen,
an welchem Standort, welchen Technologien gefragt sind und wie die auch vergütet werden.
Ein Beispiel dafür ist jobsforit.de.
Jobsforit.de ist eine deutsche Seite.
Das heißt, ihr könnt hier oben auswählen, in welchem...
Die Seite muss ich hier gleich bookmarken.
Da können wir uns das nächste Mal wieder...
jobsforit.de
Wir müssen uns mal bookmarken.
Weil...
Dark Reader, gehen wir aus.
Celery, ok, excellent.
Also, Celery, wir wollen mindestens 200k.
Moment, was?
Ich kriege... ja, ja, ok, vielleicht soll...
vielleicht... Ruby on Rails!
Das ist ja geil, da kann ich wieder ein bisschen Ruby programmieren und kriege 300.000 Euro im Jahr.
Excellent.
Ok, wahrscheinlich eher 50.000.
Das... 100% remote und 300.000 im Jahr.
Ah, excellent, ok.
Design your lifestyle as a top fre...
Hä?
Was hat denn das jetzt mit der Stellenanzeige zu tun?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Jobs come to you.
Ich dachte, das ist eine Jobanzeige.
Das ist eine Jobanzeige, in der drinne steht, dass die Jobs zu mir kommen, aber es ist kein Job.
Alles klar, klingt logisch.
Ok, also Frankfurt?
Aber in Frankfurt gibt es nicht viel.
Frankfurt?
IT-Konsulten und Problemlöser?
Troubleshooter soll das dann sein.
Also ich dachte, Troubleshooter sind Problemschützen eigentlich.
Problemlöser ist eigentlich die beste Übersetzung dafür, ja.
Ich dachte zu unseren Troubleshootern immer Problemschützen, aber ich gebe zu, das ist echt Payne's Champ.
So, Blockchain.
Payne.
Payne ist ein Blockchain-Docker.
Exzellent.
Was gibt es in.NET in Frankfurt?
30k?
Da musste aber C-Sharp-Entwickler nicht mit Leidenschaft sein, sondern mit Leidenschaft oder Ausleidenschaft, wenn man das für 30k im Jahr macht.
Als ASP.NET bist du Experte für Web-Lösungen im.NET?
Ja, ok.
Als Entwickler und Berater.
Ok, wir sind wieder in dem Fall angelangt, wo sie wieder zwei Jobs in einem eigentlich wollen.
Parallel bilden wir dich zum zertifizierten Umbr...
Was?
Was ist Umbraco?
Ah, CMS.
.NET CMS.
Hab ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo gehört.
Nach einiger Zeit wirst du außerdem Trainings durchführen als Mentor und Teamleiter.
What the fuck?
Die sind dann immer ganz dicht, Alter.
Et tu?
Also, da weiß ich echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, Alter.
Ok, Leute, ich muss mir mal einen Bookmark machen und zwar More.
Wir machen mal einen neuen Folder.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Jobs die sucken.
Weil ich wollte schon die ganze Zeit mal ein Video drüber machen, wo ich über ein paar Jobbeschreibungen im IT-Sektor herziehe.
Das ist das nicht schön.
Das ist eine schöne Sache, ja.
Jobs die sucken.
Also, ich mein, das erste ist in Ordnung.
Na?
Die suchen dir einen ASP.NET-Entwickler, dass du ASP.NET können sollst, ok.
Als Entwickler und Berater ist schon wieder ein bisschen, ah, kommt auf die Firma an, ja.
Also es ist natürlich so, dass wenn man an einem Projekt arbeitet, man das schon auch ein bisschen sich mit den Technologien natürlich auskennen muss und auch Ratschläge geben kann und auch mal gefragt wird und so.
Also ganz abwegig ist das nicht.
Aber hier gleichzustellen als Entwickler und Berater ist schon fragwürdig.
So, dann sollst du irgendein.NET CMS Experte werden, ok.
Es ist wenigstens.NET, also das passt schon.
Aber das hier ist ja der Hammer.
Nach einiger Zeit wirst du außerdem Trainings durchführen.
Also das heißt, du bist nicht nur Entwickler, du machst auch Schulungen.
Und jetzt kommt es als Mentor, na ok, und Teamleiter mit einem starken Experten-Teams gemeinsame Projekte.
Ja, was suchen die eigentlich?
Die suchen quasi ein Entwicklungs-Marketing-Teamleiter-Mensch, Management-Mensch.
So.
Übrigens musthave ist.NET, React.js und Vue.js.
Warum auch immer beides, ok.
In deinem Entwicklungsprojekt bist du an allen Projektphasen beteiligt, vom Start über Design-Epis zum Ende.
Ok, das heißt, in deinem Entwicklungsprojekt, du bist ja noch Projektmanager.
Du bist ja noch Projektmanager.
Developer-Berater-Trainer, bei uns kannst du alles sein und dich je nach Vorlieben immer wieder neu positionieren.
Ok, das heißt, du musst jeden Scheiß machen, was dein Chef gerade will.
Ok, in gewissem Maße musst du immer machen, was dein Chef gerade will.
Weil der ja auch gucken muss, dass das alles funktioniert.
Und man kann ja immer nur Sachen machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Aber das hier ist schon sehr hin und her.
Developer-Berater-Trainer übrigens noch nebenbei Projektmanager und Teamleiter.
Bei jedem Schritt deiner Entwicklung kannst du auch wissen, ok, blablabla.
Du bringst mit, ok, schauen wir mal.
Programmieren, Querdenken, Web-Lösung, gute Kenntnisse.
Erfahrungen mit Agile.
Projektgeschäft, Beratung, Fähigkeit auf Deutsch und Englisch.
Reisebereitschaft auch noch?
Ok, also der Job ist ja für 30k wahnsinnig attraktiv.
Die haben doch, die spinnen doch.
Jetzt mal ehrlich, die sind doch wirklich nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Was soll das für ein Job sein?
Junior mit Senior.
Wenn die Glück haben, finden sie einen Junior, der zu blöd ist, das zu kapieren.
Ok, was bieten die?
Zeig mal.
So arbeiten wir.
Wir arbeiten Agile, Lean und Präzise.
Partial und extrem, Alter.
Agile, Lean und Präzise.
Verwenden wir, verwenden, verwenden wir Visual Studios, ok, das ist normal.
Forschen wir stets, blablabla, akzeptieren wir, dass man dabei auch mal scheitert.
Ja, bleibt ja kaum was anderes übrig bei dem Profil.
Sitzen wir mal im Mobile-Office und mal im Büro.
Feiern wir gemeinsame Projekt-Erfolge und lassen Kollegen zu Freunden mit.
Ey, wenn man sich mit manchen Leuten so gut versteht, ist ok, aber die Arbeit sind weder Familie noch Freunde.
Das sind einfach Leute, mit denen man gut zusammenarbeiten muss, fertig.
Wenn man sich mit manchen Leuten so gut versteht, dass man auch mal was anderes machen will, ist ja in Ordnung.
Den Felix zum Beispiel kenne ich auch von der Arbeit, wir waren zusammen auf der Gamescom, verstehen uns auch so gut.
Aber man muss ja nicht automatisch die Leute mögen.
Ok, was uns egal ist, also.
Wir suchen weder Übermenschen, naja, also ehrlich gesagt doch eigentlich schon, wenn man sich die Rolle anguckt.
Noch dünnbrennt Bohrer, ich finde an sich ist die Anzeige nicht schlecht geschrieben.
Aber die Anforderungen sind schon, sind komplett, also komplett nicht von dieser Welt.
Solange du eine Arbeitserlaubnis hast, ja, das ist ja auch, sonst wird es ja auch illegal.
Agile Lean, Benefits, ok, Benefits.
Flexible Working Hours, Zuschuss zu Sportgeschichten, Home Office, ok.
Office Perks, Attractive Location, Free Snacks, Fresh Fruits, Free Drinks, ok, das ist ok.
Excellent.
Wo steht denn eigentlich, was sie bezahlen?
Oh guck mal, Office Tour, oh das ist cringe, das ist immer cringe, die Office Touren.
Das, Leute, Leute, ich sag, oh fuck, das, Leute, das wird ganz, ganz, ganz hardcore cringe werden.
Das ist immer so, diese Videos, diese Videos sind immer so zum Fremdschirm.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit auch so Werbevideos, die sind auch extrem cringe.
Hab ich euch erzählt, wo sie bei uns auf der Arbeit ein Werbevideo gedreht haben von unserem 24-7-Supporteam,
das ist da, wo ich auch im gleichen Raum sitz, wo sie festgestellt haben,
fuck, da sitzen ja fast nur mittelalte weiße Männer drin und dann haben sie noch einen Schwarzen dabei gesetzt,
eine mit Kopftuch, noch, noch zwei andere Mädels, dass das ganze Team mehr divers aussieht,
bevor das Kamerateam gekommen ist und dann den Werbefilm gedreht.
So ist das 2020, so ist das 2020.
Ok, wo sind die, wo sind die?
Ich muss mal gucken, ob das Attractive Location stimmt.
Hanover Landstraße.
Ok, ja, die ist wirklich, die Hanover Landstraße ist lang,
das ist da, wo auch der Dezix ist auf der Hanover Landstraße.
Hanover Landstraße 114.
Das ist am Ostbahnhof.
Hier ist irgendwo die EZB, da ist die EZB.
Das ist direkt am Ostbahnhof mehr oder weniger.
Das ist die Hanover Landstraße, ziemlich am Anfang von der Hanover Landstraße.
Das heißt, der Dezix kann, wo ist der KFC?
KFC Hanover Landstraße.
Ok, da, da, ok, noch ein bisschen.
Also ich kann mir immer merken, wo der Dezix in Frankfurt ist.
Der Dezix ist neben KFC.
Also wenn man sich nicht merken kann, wo der größte Internetknotenpunkt Europas ist
und einer der größten Internetknotenpunkte der Welt,
es ist neben Kentucky Fried Chicken auf der Hanover Landstraße.
Habt ihr auch wieder was gelernt?
Hier ist der Dezix.
Wenn ich weiß, was es ist, Wikipedia Eintrag,
ist der Internetknotenpunkt Frankfurt von der Meinung gemessen
am Datendurchsatz der größte der Welt.
Also der größte Internetknotenpunkt der Welt,
da neben KFC.
Das sind die, die den ganzen Kram betreiben.
Ja, der ist hier dann unterirdisch.
Hier irgendwo so, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Gebäude, die hier wahrscheinlich alle.
Das ist dann unterirdisch und da wirst du gewogen, wenn du reingehst,
dass du keinen Dreck drin lässt oder was auch immer.
Okay, Office, Office Tour, Office Tour.
Das wird cringe, ich weiß jetzt schon.
Moment, was, was, was, was, was?
Wie code.
Mit Bildchen an der Wand.
Ja, es ist eindeutig die Hanover Landstraße.
Sieht genauso hässlich aus, wie ich es in Erinnerung habe.
Wir sind übrigens auch nicht weit davon weg, deswegen ich bin da öfters mal.
Ah, Free Trinks, das ist schon mal gut.
Es ist ein bisschen, es ist so ein bisschen auf Startup Hipster gemacht,
aber das ist ja, ist ja okay, warum nicht?
Die ganze Stellenanzeige liest sich schon so.
Oh ja, niemals, nie.
Das kauf ich euch nicht ab, das ist einfach nur für das Video.
Das ist nur für das Video.
Mich interessieren mal die normalen Büros.
Wo sind denn die normalen Büros?
Habt ihr normale Büros?
Ah, hier.
Ist das eine Küche?
Ist das ein Büro oder ist das eine Küche?
Es sieht unbequem aus.
Ah, die entwickelt, die ist gerade was und entwickelt nebenbei auf dem Smartphone.
Bisschen eng, ihr wisst ja, was die Grundstückspreise da sind.
Es ist kein Wunder, dass die ihren Entwicklern kein Geld bezahlen können.
Allein schon, was die Miete kostet.
Das ist ein Büro.
Okay, es ist so eine, es ist kein Großraumbüro, aber es ist ziemlich eng.
Sind zwei oder drei Arbeitsplätze?
Zwei, zwei, vier.
Ja, mehr passt in das Büro aber auch nicht rein.
Die Stühle sehen aber wenigstens ganz gut aus.
Aber was machen die da eigentlich gerade?
Das ist auch gestellt fürs Video, Alter.
Das ist auch komplett gestellt fürs Video.
Marketing.
Nein.
BWL-Gedöns.
Azubi.
Komm mal, der Azubi.
Der Azubi ist der Einzige, der arbeitet.
Der Azubi ist der Einzige.
Das ist ja schon bezeichnet, Alter.
Der Azubi ist der Einzige, der arbeitet.
Die anderen trinken Kaffee, spielen Nerf Gun, sitzen auf der Luftmatratze.
Nur der Azubi ist am Rechner und arbeitet.
Gut, irgendeiner muss den Geld verdienen.
Der Azubi tut nur so.
Das ist ja auch der Job eines Azubis.
Okay, da wird doch was gearbeitet.
Da wird doch was gearbeitet.
Ganz schön, ganz schön eng.
Und ich frage mich, ob die eine Klimaanlage haben.
Das wird, gerade wenn es warm wird, wird das jetzt wieder witzig da.
Marketing, ja.
Das heißt, in das Büro ist das Scooter, der da steht.
Sieht aus wie Scooter von weitem, oder?
Von der Frisur her.
Naja, es ist ein bisschen, es ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen sehr Start-Up-Hipster-Style.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ja, wenn man sowas, wenn man das mag.
Ich finde es ja immer sehr aufgezwängt, diese ganzen Sachen.
Ja, na gut.
Gut genug gelästert über Jobanzeigen.
Gucken wir mal ein bisschen weiter.
Wo sind wir überhaupt stehengeblieben?
Hier in dem Video.
Tipps für die Wahl der ersten Programmiersprache.
Und wer war die Dame jetzt?
Sie stand ganz am Anfang da.
Ich habe es vergessen.
So, next.
Also, wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Ja.
Erinnert mich mal dran, da gucken wir das nächste Mal drauf, wenn wir wieder ein bisschen
Stellanzeige anschauen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ne, das ist keine Werbung für die Seite.
Ich glaube, die verwenden da wirklich selbst.
Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise einen Job als Mobile-Entwickler finden möchte in München,
dann kann ich hier einfach die Technologie auswählen.
Da bin ich bei Mobile-Entwickler.
Und dann sehe ich halt alle Angebote, die für mobile gefunden wurden.
Und hier kann man jetzt natürlich auch super auch die Gehälter vergleichen, also die
ungefähren Gehälter, also ob jetzt Mobile-Entwickler besser oder schlechter bezahlt werden als
...
Es ist wenig, ne?
Guck mal, Mobile-Entwickler für München und da gibt es ganze fünf Stellenanzeigen.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Da muss es doch viel mehr geben.
Aber, wir sehen es hier schon, wenn ich mal, okay, das ist eine Teamlead-Position hier,
bei Ride, kenne ich jetzt nicht die Firma, aber da sehen wir, dass das Gehalt bei 70.000
losgeht und bis 90.000 hochgeht.
Wenn wir jetzt mal einen Senior C++-Java-Entwickler bei ParadoxCat GmbH finden...
Ja, das kann man, das ist ja absolut nicht repräsentativ.
Ich meine, gucke mal, mobile, das sind hier sieben Stellenanzeigen, das kannst du doch
gar nicht wirklich vergleichen.
... bei 65, was die Firma von dir... und das ist natürlich auch unten in der... für
dich erfüllt.
Also überleg dir einfach mal genau, was möchtest du genau entwickeln?
Möchtest du jetzt ein Videospiel entwickeln, eine App oder deine eigene Workspace?
Das da hat er voll und ganz recht, erst mal überlegen, was man machen will.
... Seite bauen.
Hast du vielleicht schon irgendwelche Vorkenntnisse, die dir dabei helfen können, direkt eine
schwierige Programmiersprache zu lernen?
Ja, ich habe 5er-KD.
Und pass auf den Arbeitsmarkt auf.
Ich kann dir aber den Rat geben, nicht den Fehler zu machen, verschiedene Programmiersprachen
auf einmal zu lernen, vor allem, wenn ihr absolute Neulinge seid.
Versucht erst mal richtig gut in einer Programmiersprache...
Also ich würde das in die Bewerbung auch reinschreiben, wenn man eine 5er-KD hat,
ne?
... denn wenn ihr eine Programmiersprache richtig gut beherrscht, dann fällt es euch
später viel leichter, Neusprachen dazu zu lernen, weil sich grundlegende Konzepte eigentlich
überhaupt nicht ändern.
Ja, so sieht's aus, so sieht's aus.
Wenn ihr dich für iOS interessiert, dann kann... Nö, das Genre... na ja, doch, das
ist eine der einzigen Fragen, die ihr halt stellen müsst, das willst du in 2D machen
oder in 3D-Game.
Wobei ich halt im Gaming-Bereich nicht viel Ahnung habe.
... ein paar Videos auf meinem Kanal hier anschauen, da habe ich euch mal eins oben
verlinkt in den Infokarten.
Ansonsten hoffe ich, dass ich euch mit dem Video zu einer kleinen Starthilfe geben kann.
Ja, er hat schon recht, er hat schon recht.
... in all eurer ersten Programmiersprache.
Das war es jetzt auch mit diesem Video, ich würde mich super über ein Abo freuen, also
der Kanal hat so viel... Exzellent.
... Finanz bekommen, das motiviert mich natürlich viel mehr, derartige Videos zu machen.
Nice.
Ach, guck, ja genau, als nächstes gucken wir uns mal den Bauer, äh, sorry, der Auer,
den Auer gucken wir uns an, der, ähm, den, äh, 1090K overclockt, also die CPU ist Mist,
das haben wir uns ja im letzten Stream schon mal angeguckt an Benchmarks, seien den ihr
möchte 1000 Euro für 1-2 FPS mehr ausgeben, dann ist es natürlich gut.
Ähm, aber ich gucke dem Bauer immer gerne beim übertanken zu, einfach weil ich das
selbst nie machen werde mit Flüssigstickstoff, weil es ja auch keinen Sinn macht eigentlich
daheim, im Dauerbetrieb, das ist einfach nur, um zu gucken was maximal geht, wirklich Sinn.
Flüssigstickstoff übertanken ist so ein Ding, es macht eigentlich unterm Strich absolut
keinen Sinn, weil man es nicht betreiben kann auf Dauer, aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie
cool.
Wie ihr mittlerweile wahrscheinlich mitbekommen habt, ist Comet Lake jetzt da, also die neuen
Intel 10-Kerner Prozessoren sind jetzt verfügbar, bzw. die ersten Videos werden online gehen,
zum Zeitpunkt wo wir dieses Video gerade drehen, ist es jetzt gerade Anfang April.
Ne, ne, ne, also SnackerTV, ähm, der 770K war quasi der, der erste dieser Generation
mehr oder weniger, und jetzt ist halt der 1090K der neueste, also ich hab nen 8700K und wir
haben letztens mal nen Benchmark gemacht und halt unter wirklich nicht optimalen Bedingungen
und ich war fast genauso schnell wie nen 1090K Single, Single, Single Core Performance.
Deswegen ist es für mich so ein bisschen schwierig, so ein paar Informationen noch.
Warte mal, ich glaub die Katze kratzt an der Tür, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Naja, gut, so, exzellent, da sind wir wieder, also, dann gucken wir uns mal an wie der Bauer
das Ding mit Flüssigstickstoff übertaktet.
Einzuordnen, zum Beispiel ganz, ganz lustig, auf dem Mainboard bei mir steht drauf LGA
1200, also auf der Sockelabdeckung, und hier im CPU-Z steht drin LGA 1159, das war für
mich grad auch schon ein bisschen verwirrend, aber es ist LGA 1200, sonst würde das auch
nicht auf dem Sockel draufstehen.
Ich hab von Intel an dieser Stelle noch keine offiziellen Informationen, die CPU hab ich
mir auch wieder auf andere Weise besorgt und wir werden jetzt gleich mal ausprobieren.
Doch das ist vom Mai, das Video ist ja schon alt, egal, interessiert mich trotzdem.
Wie der CPU mit Flüssigstickstoff möglich ist, grundsätzlich, was die Leistung betrifft
und so weiter, da wird es zum Release...
Intel ist komplett RIP, was CPU auf dem Desktop angeht, wenn die nächste Ryzen-Generation
rauskommt.
Den einzigen Vorteil, den Intel aktuell noch hat, ist Single-Core, beziehungsweise Spiele-Performance,
wenn nicht viele Kerne, sondern nur ein paar Kerne dafür schnell gebraucht werden.
Da hast du ein bisschen Vorteil, sag mal mal 10% vielleicht noch, Vorteile gegenüber einem
aktuellen Ryzen, wenn es hochkommt, je nach Game auch nur, wenn die nächste Ryzen-Generation
rauskommt und nochmal 15% oder vielleicht sogar 20-25% drauflegt, dann ist Intel weg
vom Fenster.
Komm, dann ist fertig, dann noch nicht mal Spiele-Performance.
Das Einzige, was Intel dann machen kann, ist noch selektiertere Chips rausbringen, die
vielleicht noch ein paar Takt, noch ein bisschen mehr Takt packen oder halt mal mit einer neuen
Architektur um die Ecke kommen oder halt die Sachen massiv günstiger machen.
Mal schauen, ich bin echt gespannt, was da rauskommt dieses Jahr.
Es wird von dieser CPU wahrscheinlich dutzende andere Overclocker oder YouTuber geben, die
da Review-Content erstellen werden, das heißt wir werden jetzt nicht irgendwelche Game-Benchmarks
oder sowas machen, sondern wir focusieren uns rein darauf, was ist Overclocking technisch
mit dieser CPU möglich und das vor allem mit flüssigem Stickstoff.
Wir wissen ja vom 9900K, der von der Architektur her sehr sehr ähnlich ist, dass diese CPUs,
sehr gute CPUs, so in der Regel etwas über 7 GHz schaffen mit flüssigem Stickstoff.
Ich hoffe, dass wir in dieser Region hier vordringen können, ich weiß nicht genau,
was die CPU schafft, das werden wir im heutigen Video testen und dafür müssen wir natürlich
erstmal das ganze Mainboard vorbereiten, das heißt isolieren mit Liquid Tape, dann fangen
wir an, bauen Flüssig-Stickstoff-Kühler drauf, ich habe selber das Teil noch überhaupt
nicht getestet, also ich habe so Minimalerfahrung, was, ich weiß nicht mehr, Katze, was machst
du?
Wann geht das Übertakten los?
Die Katze muss das analysieren, was ist da sonst los?
Das ist Werbung für eine Maus, okay.
Wo wird übertaktet?
Ich will mal das Übertakten angucken.
Das Vorbereiten kennen wir ja schon mittlerweile.
Oh, ah yes, erstmal schön irgendein Lack drauf, Leute Übertakter-Profis, warum kommt
da so ein komischer Lack drauf, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, dass das kein Kondenswasser
abkriegt oder so.
Okay, wir haben jetzt das Mainboard über Nacht trocknen lassen, weil ich doch relativ
viel Flüssigummi aufgetragen habe und ich will einfach sicher sein, dass es alles trocken
ist, dass es da zu keinen Problemen kommt und habe mich jetzt entschlossen, dass wir
noch kurz einen Test mit einem Wasserkühler machen, weil ich weiß wirklich überhaupt
gar nicht, was die CPU kann.
Also, wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass es ähnlich ist wie jetzt 9900K oder 9900KS,
aber ich weiß eben nicht.
Das fängt fast aus wie Lippenstift, oder?
Irgendwie so.
Wir machen einen kleinen Vortest mit Wasserkühlung und wenn wir das gemacht haben, dann testen
wir das Ganze mit Flüssigstückstoff weiter, aber es ist auf jeden Fall gut, so einen Basicscore
zu haben, dass wir wissen, okay, so ist die Leistung bei 5,3 Gigahertz oder was auch immer
die CPU können wird, weil dann wissen wir, bei diesem Setting, was wir einstellen, ist
die CPU auf jeden Fall immer stabiler und vor allem der RAM, das ist ja eher so ein
größeres Problem bei Flüssigstückstoff-Overclocking, sodass man dann irgendwann irgendwelche Stabilitätsprobleme
bekommt und dann gar nicht weiß, woher die Probleme so genau kommen und das wollen wir
vermeiden.
Wasserkühlung kann ich auf genau die gleiche Montage draufballern, wie ich das auch mit
einem Flüssigstückstoffkühler mache, deswegen ist das ganz angenehm, das so zu testen.
Wir werden übrigens den allerersten Slot verwenden, das ist ein X4 PC-Express-Slot,
also der benutzt ja quasi nur so den Anfang der Grafikkarte, weil der ist nämlich an
den Chipsats angebunden und der Chipsats hat kein Problem mit PC-Express, während die
CPU Probleme mit PC-Express bekommen kann, wenn man die zu kalt macht.
Und wenn man das Problem nicht gehen möchte, benutzt man einfach nur die Lanes, die direkt
an den Chipsats angeschlossen sind, deswegen musste ich jetzt auch die M2 SSD oben aufstehen.
JuicyJuice, ich weiß nicht, wie du meinst.
Das Apex-Board hat glücklicherweise mittlerweile einen On-Board-Slot, aber wenn trotzdem das
System...
Ich will über Takten sehen.
Als wäre das mal Wasser nachgefüllt.
Also die CPU kann 5,2 Gigahertz...
Ist das überhaupt Wasser oder ist das Wasser mit irgendeinem Zeug drinnen?
Bei 1,30 Volt durch alle Benchmarks, auch mit Cinebench R20, was ja auch VX verwendet.
Cinebench R15 geht auf 5,3 Gigahertz, aber das ist dann halt eben nicht mehr stabil durch
alle Benchmarks.
Die CPU macht maximal 5,1 Gigahertz All-Core mit glaube dann 4 minus 4 AVX Offset und ich
glaube 1,325 V-Core.
Ah, ich weiß es nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Max und ihr wollt ja wahrscheinlich wissen, was man von diesen CPUs erwarten kann.
Wenn man versucht, die CPU mit 5,3 Gigahertz durch den Cinebench R20 durchzuprügeln, dann
wird die einfach unfassbar warm, auch schon so bei 1,3, 2, 1,3, 4 Volt und man bekommt
die Wärme einfach auch nicht weg.
1,3, 1,4 ich glaube ich habe maximal 1,37 oder?
Kann man sich nicht merken, wenn man nicht gerade der Bauer ist, der kann sich das alles
merken.
Aber klar, wenn man das den ganzen Tag wartet.
Will Benchmarks sehen, let's go Benchmarks, exzellent.
Da haben wir dann im Cinebench R15 2822 Punkte, im Multi 230 Punkte im Single, im R20 haben
wir 6761 und 540 im Single und hier seht ihr auch Temmrat.
Das sieht man mal, große Unterschied, ist es nett, wir hatten letztens unter ungünstigen
Bedingungen glaube ähnliche Sachen oder 480 oder sowas und das war halt während dem Streamen
mit 4M und allem an und sind sinnlos gesetzt im AVX Offset.
Der filmt sein Bildschirm ab, ja anscheinend, wird nicht gecaptchert, AVX macht halt warm.
Jetzt kommt der Tank obendrauf, da ist er.
So, wir fühlen jetzt um vom 30 Liter Behälter in die kleinen Thermos kann.
Ist das Absicht, dass ihr Bobbes in die Kamera hält jetzt?
Die Frau muss die schwere Arbeit machen, der Mann die leichte.
So, jetzt wird erstmal Flüssigstix da rumgefällt und jetzt gehts los, Chat!
Ich finde ja das Geräusch super, wenn man Flüssigstix auf irgendwo reinschüttet und
dann so anfängt zu blubbern.
Ok, wir sind jetzt bei fast minus 100 Grad Celsius, wir haben hier den LN2 Mode aktiviert,
das ist was, das solltet ihr wirklich nur tun, wenn ihr negativen Temperaturbereich verwendet
und dann haben wir hier Reset.
Was ist der LN2 Mode?
Die schalten wir jetzt auch um und damit versuchen wir jetzt so zu starten und hoffen, dass
alles funktioniert.
Ahja, alles klar, der LN2 Mode.
Ab so minus 60, minus 70 Grad Celsius kann man sich noch einen anderen sehr interessanten
Effekt zunutze machen und zwar gibt es ja den Leidenfrosteffekt, der verhindert, dass
der Wärmeübergang vernünftig ist zwischen dem Flüssigstixstoff und dem festen Kühlkörper,
da bildet sich so eine Gasschicht.
Um das Ganze so ein bisschen zu beschleunigen, dass der Flüssigstixstoff schneller runterkühlt,
kann man einfach mit der Heatgun in den Kühler reinhalten und durch die Umgebungsfeuchte,
die wir in der Luft haben, schlägt sich ja wie hier außen am Kühler so ein bisschen
Eis nieder und dadurch, durch diese Eiskristalle, wird diese Gasschicht gebrochen und der Kühler
kühlt viel viel schneller runter als sonst, also das ist ein Trick, den man mit dem Flüssigstixstoff
absolut empfehlen kann.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Wir sind jetzt bei knapp minus 90, man sieht es wirklich, also wenn ich das einfülle,
alleine die Nebelentwicklung, die man dadurch sieht und wie schnell es dadurch runterkühlt,
da sieht man den Unterschied durch die Kristalle im Kühler.
Wir haben jetzt noch nicht tief genug Temperatur, um zu starten, das liegt an den Reserve-Switches,
die haben ein paar Spannungen im Hintergrund angehoben und die sind so hoch, dass die CPU
einfach im Normalbetrieb nicht starten kann.
Dafür ist die CPU quasi immer noch zu warm, immer noch bei minus 96 Grad Celsius ist die
CPU zu warm dafür.
Also, minus 96 Grad ist nicht genug.
Deswegen haben wir auf dem Mainboard, auf der Debug-LED auch immer noch 0,0 und jetzt
muss ich so lange runterkühlen und dann immer wieder den Retry-Knopf drücken, der ist hier,
der ist übrigens genau dafür da, der übernimmt die vorhandenen BIOS-Einstellungen einfach
immer wieder und wenn es dann tief genug ist, kalt genug, dann startet es irgendwann.
Na, Shig, ist es dir nicht so ganz geheuer?
Meine Katze hätte sich schon längst verpisst, wenn ich sowas mache.
Meine Katze muss leider heute draußen bleiben, das ist zu gefährlich für die Meets, nicht
dass da irgendwas passiert.
Wirklich extrem overclocking heutzutage, ich will nicht sagen, dass es ein Kindergeburtstag
ist, aber das ist so viel einfacher als früher.
Wirklich, ich habe mich mit dieser Plattform jetzt eigentlich null beschäftigt, also effektiv
zwei, drei Stunden und alles, was ich mit dem Apex-Bot gemacht habe, ist 1,45 VCC EO im
BIOS eingestellt, PLL-Termination-Spannung 1,75, die Schale überlegt.
Ja, die PLL-Termination-Spannung, ja die darf man nicht vergessen, ist klar.
Jetzt haben wir hier geschmeidige 180 Grad Celsius, eigentlich total easy, die Thermometer
weichen immer ein bisschen ab, die sind nicht für diesen Temperaturbereich gemacht, eigentlich
müsste der jetzt so minus 190 Grad anzeigen, sowas in der Richtung, tut er aber eben nicht.
Auf jeden Fall ist das einfach der Wahnsinn, wie einfach das heutzutage funktioniert, mit
so einem Board, das einfach dafür gemacht ist.
Früher hätte man da zig tausend Mods und Kram installieren müssen und selbst dann
hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht funktioniert, weil ich habe jetzt einfach mal 1,75 voll
eingestellt.
1,75?
Okay, das ist viel, ich glaube bei meiner CPU sind es 1,32 oder sowas, 1,75, okay, mich
würde mal interessieren, was das Ding an Stromverbrauch hat dann.
Kann es nochmal laufen lassen für euch, also hier jetzt Artis Turbo V-Core geöffnet, 1,75
CPU-Kernspannung einfach auf 6 Gigahertz hochgezogen, können jetzt auch einfach mal 6,2 machen,
das wird auch ohne Probleme laufen, sehen wir hier CPU-Z 6,2 Gigahertz, das ist eine WPF-Anwendung,
dass es eine WPF-Anwendung ist, erkennt man an dem hässlichen Frontrendering auf dem
Frontend, können wir kurz einen Lauf machen, das Flutsch, 3250 Punkte circa im R15, also
wirklich unfassbar wie einfach das heutzutage ist, wir machen jetzt mal kurz einen Versuch,
die 7 Gigahertz Marke anzukratzen, mein aktueller Rekord mit 9900K sind ja 7,6 Gigahertz, der
Rekord steht übrigens immer noch, dann hat keiner gebrochen seit dem ersten Tag, aber
der war auch mit Flüssighelium gemacht, also ein bisschen unfair, Flüssighelium ist ja
nochmal knapp 60 Grad, knapp 70 Grad kälter als das hier und dementsprechend mit Flüssig-Schickstoff
eigentlich nicht wirklich zu erreichen, ich bin jetzt bei aktuell 6,8 Gigahertz, 1,84
Volt ungefähr und wir versuchen jetzt mal 7 Gigahertz auf allen Kernen zu machen, mich
würde der Stromverbrauch echt interessieren, Twitch Zuschauer, das funktioniert nicht,
Twitch Zuschauer sagt, ins Weltanschießen, da ist das Ding kalt genug, nee ist es nicht,
es ist zwar im Weltall kalt, aber du hast so gut wie keine ordentliche Wärmeleitung,
da ist ja nichts, das ist ja Vakuum, Vakuum leitet nicht, also es bringt gar nichts, wenn
du einen CPU-Kühler ins Weltall hängst, das kühlt nicht, also der CPU-Kühler kühlt,
aber der Kühler wird nicht kühlen.
Das war zu viel, das Maximum was wir jetzt bisher rausholen konnten waren ca.
7250 Mhz, einmal haben wir 7,3 Gigahertz kurz gehabt, aber der ist eben direkt gecrashed,
ich denke das ist so einigermaßen das Limit von der CPU, wenn ich mich jetzt da lange hinsetzen
würde und hätte nochmal 100 Liter Flüssig Schickstoff, bin ich mir sicher, dass man
das noch um so 100 Mhz locker steigern könnte, gerade weil man da noch ein bisschen Feintuning
machen kann, mit Spannungen erhöhen und senken, da gibt es ja viel was man da rumspielen
kann, wir haben leider nicht ganz so viel, die 30 Liter die wir haben, die müssen auch
noch für ein anderes Video reichen, deswegen machen wir auf jeden Fall Schluss bei der
maximalen CPU-Z-Validierung und gehen jetzt mal über zur Cinebench, es ist halt so, dass
wir bei allem was wir jetzt gerade testen, immer, was kosten sowas, was kosten 30 Liter
Flüssig Schickstoff?
Warum erfriert man dann den Weltraum ohne Anzug, weiß ich nicht, erfriert man den Weltraum
ohne Anzug?
Ich weiß nicht ob das schon mal jemand ausprobiert hat, du wirst wahrscheinlich eher ersticken
und je nach Sonneneinstrahlung auch Strahlungsprobleme haben, im All fängt dein Blut an zu kochen,
das halte ich für ein Gerücht, okay, das ist ganz schön teuer, wegen dem Druckunterschied,
das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht, da muss man sich aber mal mit Physikzeug beschäftigen,
alle 10 Kerne und auch Hyperthreading aktiv haben, das heißt alle 20 Threads sind aktiv,
bei diesen CPUs ist es interessanterweise möglich das Hyperthreading pro Core abzuschalten,
das heißt rein theoretisch ist das möglich 10 Kerne und 14 Threads zum Beispiel zu verwenden,
ist eine sehr interessante Funktion, also gerade wenn man irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen
Berechnungen hat, was auch immer, man weiß, okay das Programm benutzt genau 14 Threads,
dann kann man das auf 14 senken statt 20 und dann sollte das effektiver laufen, das kann
man auch bei vielen Benchmarks machen, ich wollte eigentlich auch darauf hinaus, weil
viele, wenn sie solche CPU-Z-Validierungen machen, dann deaktivieren die gerne mal Hyperthreading,
deaktivieren die gerne mal Kerne und dann sagen sie, oh ich habe hier mit meinem 10.900K
7,8 GHz erreicht und dann schaut man sich das Ergebnis an und dann ist es nur auf eine
von 10 Kernen und aus meiner Sicht zählt sowas einfach nicht, weil dann kann ich es
auch mit einem Vierkerner machen oder mit einem Sechskerner, dann kann man das Spiel
gleich lassen, deswegen alles was ich mache, immer volle Anzahl Kerne, volle Anzahl Threads,
das ist aus meiner Sicht das einzig Sinnvolle.
Da wird der Google Antworten zählen erstmal nicht, je nachdem von welcher Seite die kommen.
Bei Cinebench müssen wir die Spannung ein bisschen senken, bei CPU-Z hatten wir bis
zu 1,9 Volt gerade, Cinebench wird ja ein bisschen mehr von der Last, dementsprechend
Leistungsaufnahme wesentlich höher, wir können auch gleich mal mit einer Stromzange versuchen
zu schauen, was die Leistungsaufnahme ist, die sollte mit Physik Schickstoff gar nicht
so hoch sein, ich schätze mal so 250 bis 300 Watt, viel mehr wird das wahrscheinlich nicht
sein, vielleicht sogar 350, aber denke mal das wars dann, dementsprechend verwenden wir
ein bisschen niedrigere Spannung, ca. 1,65, 1,75 Volt sowas in der Richtung, vielleicht
bis zu 1,85, mal schauen wie es skaliert, probieren wir das mal aus.
Soweit sieht es schon mal sehr sehr gut aus, also der aktuelle Rekord im Cinebench R15
ist übrigens 3410 Punkte, das ist mit einem 10900X, also Cascade Lake X, das ist ja von
dem Sockel 2066, was, es gibt ein 10900X, ich blicke bei Intel Bezeichnungen nicht mehr
durch, das ist mir zu big brain, das haben wir jetzt schonmal ganz easy geschlagen, also
es ist quasi schonmal ein neuer Weltrekord mit dem 10-Kerner, ich bin mir relativ sicher
das andere Overclocker auch noch mit der CPU was machen, also kann sein, dieser Score wird
wahrscheinlich eine Woche nach Launch auch überboten werden, sind jetzt aber schonmal
bei 3468 Punkte, bei 6,5 GHz auf dem Kern und 6,2 GHz auf dem Cache und ich versuche
jetzt das mal noch ein bisschen weiter zu prügeln, aber ich bin mir zuversichtlich, dass man
den alten Weltrekord sehr sehr hoch überbieten wird.
Es gibt noch was anderes kleines, das ich euch kurz zeigen möchte oder ich möchte,
dass ihr das hören könnt, also wenn ich hier nochmal Physikstückstoff einfülle, dann
ist das einfach so ein bisschen so ein kochendes Geräusch, ich hoffe ihr könnt das ein bisschen
hören über das Mikrofon, wenn ich dann jetzt gleich diesen Benchmark hier starte, also
ich habe jetzt 6,6 GHz bei 1,8 Volt circa und das ist schon ordentlich, das ist schon
ordentlich Leistung, die da abgeführt werden muss und wenn ich das gleich starte, dann
werdet ihr sehen, wie das in dem Kühler viel viel stärker anfängt zu kochen, weil eben
die Leistung abgeführt werden muss und die Leistung wird abgeführt dadurch, dass eben
der Flüssig-Schickstoff verdampft.
Boah, das sieht ja geil aus.
Das könnt ihr mir ganzen Tag lang gucken.
Man sieht dann eben auch, sobald der Benchmark vorbei ist, dann hört es auch wieder auf,
so stark zu blubbern.
Das Maximum, was ich jetzt so spontan machen konnte, waren so knapp über 6,7 GHz auf allen
Kernen, was für ein 10-Core schon echt ordentlich ist, das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Ihr seht, ich habe auch einen Single-Score für euch mal kurz gemacht im R15, das ist
immer fast bei 300 Punkten, das ist natürlich schon echt enorm viel.
Multihammer 3561, ich starte den gleich nochmal, dass ihr seht, wie das läuft bei 6,7 GHz,
aber das wird jetzt so...
Das ist wirklich schon echt viel.
Es ist halt absolut praxisuntauglich und deswegen ziemlich egal, aber es ist cool,
dass es funktioniert.
3.600 Punkte.
Damit ca. 200 Punkte über dem aktuellen Weltrekord, kann es sich auf jeden Fall sehen lassen.
Natürlich könnte man da jetzt noch ein bisschen extra Performance rausholen, wahrscheinlich
so um die 100 Punkte im R15, also wenn man jetzt noch mehr Zeit verbringt, die CPU maximal
ausloadet, hier beim Cache vielleicht noch 100-200 MHz rausholt und natürlich auch den
RAM vernünftig einstellt, weil der ist jetzt einfach nur 3.800 C16, das ist jetzt nicht
die Welt, das ist einfach nur ein sicheres Basic-Setting für den RAM.
Da kann man auf jeden Fall noch locker um die 100 Punkte rausholen, nichtsdestotrotz auf
die schnelle 200 Punkte über dem aktuellen Weltrekord, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal
zufriedenstellend.
Damit kommen wir jetzt auch zum Ende von dem Video.
Grundsätzlich muss man sagen, die CPUs von Intel lassen sich nach wie vor wunderbar
übertacken, die skalieren einfach unfassbar gut mit Kälte.
Es ist aber auch beim 10900K das gleiche, wie es schon beim 9900K war und beim 8700K
und beim 7700K und beim 6700K, also es hat sich eigentlich so vom grundsätzlichen Overclocking
nicht viel geändert, bis auf das die Boards natürlich deutlich besser geworden sind und
das Leben für uns so viel einfacher geworden ist, also wirklich, wenn man sich ein bisschen
damit auseinandersetzt, wie man so mit Physik-Schickstoff arbeitet bei Physik-Schickstoff-Overclocking,
dann kommt man an einem Tag auf jeden Fall auf endliche Ergebnisse, macht auf jeden
Fall eben Spaß, muss ich mir ganz klar sagen, finde ich immer wieder cool.
Wir hören jetzt an dieser Stelle auch auf, weil auf dem Mainboard an der Seite hat sich
tatsächlich an dem Bereich, wo wir auch nicht isoliert haben, sehr viel Eis und auch so
ein bisschen Kondenswasser gebildet und da das mein einziges Board ist für diesen Sockel
und auch die einzige CPU, werden wir jetzt das nicht weiter riskieren.
Die Ergebnisse sind trotzdem sehr schön, über 7,2 GHz auf allen Kernen bei CPU-Z und
6,7 GHz, ein bisschen über 6,7 GHz im Cinebench R15 für 10 Kerne, sehr sehr cool, also CPUs,
die machen mit Overclocking auf jeden Fall Spaß.
Damit verabschiede ich mich von diesem Video, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, macht
es gut, bis dahin, ciao.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt auch noch mal an.
wenn ein Typ mit Notebook und Hoodie vor deinem Fenster sitzt.
Ne, vor dem Fenster geht nicht, in deinem Keller, in deinem Keller.
Ja.
Hacker-Mens.
Das erste Anzeichen ist ziemlich offensichtlich, wenn dein Gerät ein Eigenleben entwickelt,
dann solltest du unbedingt darüber nachdenken, es von einem Fachmann überprüfen zu lassen,
da reicht schon, wenn man Windows installiert hat, oder selbst Hand anzulegen.
Zu diesem Eigenleben zählen beispielsweise seltsame Bewegungen des Mauszeigers, die
ohne dein Zutun wie von Geisterhand geschehen.
Auch wenn sich Dateien von selbst verschieben oder installieren, könnte dein Rechner einen
ungebetenen Gast beherbergen.
Du solltest also das Verhalten...
Wie gesagt, dafür reicht schon Windows, da installieren sich auch genug Sachen von allein.
...beobachten und in Alarmbereitschaft sein, wenn irgendetwas auf deinem Desktop geschieht,
was du dir nicht erklären kannst.
Insbesondere dann, wenn du nicht zu der entsprechenden Aktion beiträgst.
Wenn sich dein Gerät häufiger aufhängt oder mit der Abarbeitung seiner Tasks überlastet
ist, dann könnte es sein, dass neben deinen normalerweise verwendeten Anwendungen...
...Bitcoins laufen, die deinen Rechner schaden beziehungsweise ihn ausschöpfen.
Dazu reicht es auch, wenn man die Webseite von Cristiano Ronaldo besucht, da wird auch
mal schön Monero gemeint.
Oder E-Serial, ich weiß, Monero, Monero hat er gemeint.
...dann, wenn dieser Leistungsabfall plötzlich auftritt, lohnt dein Blick in den Taskmanager.
Möglicherweise bist du Teil eines Botnetzes geworden.
Auch im Autostart kannst du nachsehen, ob sich dort neue Programme befinden, die vorher
noch nicht dort waren.
Nicht Bitcoins, Monero hat er gemeint.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann solltest du diese Programme erstmal aus dem Autostart nehmen
und recherchieren, was es mit ihnen auf sich hat.
Danach solltest du die Programme von deinem Rechner entfernen.
Malware und insbesondere Spyware verbrauchen zusätzliche Rechenkapazitäten.
Da man bei Programmieren solcher Malware oft nicht den klassischen Weg über die Appschnittstellen
gehen kann, müssen Umwege geschaffen werden, die wiederum viel Strom verbrauchen.
Wenn der Akku deines mobilen Endgeräts also von jetzt auf gleich erhebliche Leistungen
einbüßt, dann kann das ein Indikator dafür sein, dass sich Malware auf deinem Rechner
befindet.
Du solltest also nachsehen, welche Apps derzeit laufen und schrittweise versuchen nachzuvollziehen,
was die einzelnen Dienste auf deinem Gerät eigentlich machen.
Wenn der Angreifer aus einem anderen Land kommt, kann er aufgrund der Zeitverschiebung
berechnen, wann günstige Zeitpunkte für externe Zugriffes sind und wann man gegebenenfalls
sein Smartphone lädt.
Da würde die Malware unter Umständen gar nicht auffallen, da sie primär während der
Ladezeiten arbeiten.
Bei stationären Rechnern ist das alles etwas schwieriger festzustellen, da sie ja am Strom
hängen und somit nicht leer gehen, außer zum Beispiel bei Laptops.
In diesem Fall kannst du einen Stromzähler zwischen deinem Netzteil und die Steckdose
schalten, um den Stromverbrauch zu messen.
Doch das ist ohne entsprechende Referenzwerte, also vor dem Angriff nicht wirklich aussagekräftig.
Wenn deine Online-Suchanfragen häufiger mal auf andere Seiten umgeleitet werden, dann
kann das ein Zeichen dafür sein, dass jemand eine Malware installiert hat, der versucht
dich auf Fake-Seiten zu lotsen.
Hierfür kann zum Beispiel DNS-Cash-Poisoning oder man hat sich früher so eine komische
Browser Toolbar installiert, ein Clipboard-Highjacker verwendet werden.
Ziel ist es, dich zur Eingabe von sensiblen Daten zu bewegen oder Zahlungen anzuweisen,
die dann nicht beim eigentlichen Empfänger, sondern bei dem Hacker ankommen.
Wenn dich dein Rechner übertrieben aggressiv vor möglichen Bedrohungen warnt, solltest
du vor allem jetzt sagen, nicht unbedingt, weil...
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist oftmals ein Trick.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch so angesagt ist, das hat früher, gab es ganz viele Fake-Antivirus-Software,
die eigentlich gar keine Antivirus-Software war, die dann von dir wollte, dass du eine
Lizenz für die Antivirus-Software kaufst und sowas.
...eine Bedrohung vor der Tür steht, sondern weil du möglicherweise schon gehackt wurdest.
Solche Scareware-Popups warnen dich vor Gefahren, die eigentlich gar nicht da sind bzw. die
schon da sind und durch eben dieses Scareware verursacht werden.
Der Anbender soll dazu bewegt werden, sich eine Software zu kaufen, die ihn angeblich
vor diesen Gefahren schützt.
Dass diese Software selbst die eigentliche Gefahr ist, ist das besonders perfide daran.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass der Angräfer dadurch doppelt abkassiert, nämlich einmal
durch den Verkauf der Software und durch die zusätzlichen Rechte, die gegebenenfalls mit
der Installation eingereunt werden.
Versuche, die Verursacher solcher Popups zu deinstallieren.
Warnhinweise können aber auch berechtigt sein, wenn sie z.B. von deinem Antiviren-Popup kommen,
diese auch unbedingt beachtet werden, denn wenn schon die zum Großteil von neuen Angriffen
völlig blinden Virenprogramme Alarm schlagen, dann ist es höchste Zeit, dein System einmal
gründlich zu checken und gegebenenfalls zu bereinigen.
Da hat er Recht.
Viele Unterdienste bieten mittlerweile eine Multifaktor-Authentifizierung für...
Ja, kann man nur empfehlen.
Sollte man, sofern man den Dienst öfters verwendet und da sensible Sachen drin sind, wichtig ist,
das soll man überall einschalten.
Es gibt ein paar Anbieter, die es bis heute nicht hinkriegen, was gescheites anzubieten,
aber gut, die meisten haben es zum Glück.
MFA an, die dich bei neuen Anmeldungen darüber benachrichtigt, dass jemand versucht hat,
sich in deinen Account einzuloggen.
Wenn du das nicht warst, hast du bei eingeschalteter Multifaktor-Authentifizierung die Möglichkeit,
eine solche Anmeldung zu verhindern.
Google speichert z.B. sehr viele Daten über dich.
Auch wenn das normalerweise schlecht ist, könnte sich dieser Umstand hier sogar als Vorteil
herausstellen, da du bis ins kleinste Detail nachvollziehen kannst, wann und von wo aus
dein Account verwendet wurde.
Wenn du deinen Tagesablauf rekonstruierst und weißt, dass du dich um 13.15 Uhr nicht
im Pyongyang aufgehalten hast, dann solltest du schleudigst ein neues Passwort vergeben
und Google bei einer möglichen Übernahme deines Accounts informieren.
Nimm also Hinweise von deinem Accountbetreiber ernst.
Achte aber darauf, dass diese Benachrichtigungen authentisch sind.
Viele Hacker versenden nämlich per E-Mail Benachrichtigungen über angebliche Anmeldungen
und verleiten den Anwender dazu, sich durch einen Klick auf bestimmte Buttons in Gefahr
zu begeben.
So könnten Daten abgegriffen werden oder am schlimmsten Fall erhält der Angreifer
sogar Zugriff auf deinen Account.
Wenn dich Bekannte auf Nachrichten ansprechen, die du angeblich geschrieben hast, an die
du dich allerdings nicht erinnern kannst, dann könnte es sein, dass jemand deinen Account
mitnimmt.
Das Video ist nicht schlecht.
Es gilt natürlich auch für solche Media-Posts, die du nie abgesetzt hast, wie etwa Instagram-Bilder.
Meine ehemalige Deutschlehrerin ist mal Opfer eines Hacking-Angriffs auf ihren E-Mail-Account
geworden und der Angreifer hat dann an alle Adressen in der Kontaktliste seltsame Test-Mails
verschickt.
Natürlich haben die meisten Kontakte sie direkt darauf angesprochen, wodurch das Problem
schnell behoben werden konnte.
Bedenke, dass du durch den nachlässigen Umgang mit Passwörtern nach deinen Mitmenschen
schadest, wenn die Besuchung in deinem Postfach, einschließlich mir, wurden dann auch zu Hacken
versucht.
Es lohnt sich also durchaus, hin und wieder mal in die gesendeten Nachrichten deines
E-Mail-Postfachs zu schauen.
Wenn der Angreifer seine Spuren nicht beseitigt hat und sich dort Nachrichten findet, die
du gar nicht gesendet hast, solltest du umgehend dein E-Mail-Passwort ändern.
Wenn du auf einmal eine Flut an Spam-Mails erhältst, ist das möglicherweise ein Zeichen
dafür, dass jemand deine E-Mail-Adresse gekapert hat und sie auf diversen Plattformen verwendet,
die dann wiederum entweder selbst Spam-Mails verschicken oder deine E-Mail-Adresse weiterverkaufen.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass z.B. dein Paypal-Account gehackt wurde und eine Flut an
E-Mails dafür sorgen soll, dass Mails über erfolgte Abbuchungen von deinem Konto in der
schieren Masse untergehen.
Denn kaum jemand wird 500 E-Mails nacheinander durchgehen und überprüfen, ob irgendwo eine
von Paypal dabei ist.
In solchen Fällen lohnt es sich, deine Kontodaten direkt auf der Plattform einzusehen.
Ein guter Indikator ist auch der Verkehr in deinem Netzwerk.
Das stimmt, das werden die meisten Leute aber nicht überprüfen können.
Was ich ganz praktisch finde ist, ab und zu mal gucken, ich weiß, also es gibt genug
Sachen hier drin, die nicht auftauen, was ich ganz praktisch finde, immer wenn der Rechner
mal komische Dinge macht, einfach mal im Processexplorer gucken, was da wieder im Hintergrund läuft.
Gar nicht so im Hinblick auf irgendwie Malware oder sonst was, sondern weil einem da Dinge
auffallen, die man bisher noch gar nicht wusste, z.B. der Auto-Updater vom Chrome, wann der
läuft oder solche Geschichten.
Wenn du eine Internetverbindung hattest und sie plötzlich verlangsamt wird, dann könnte
das ein Zeichen dafür sein, dass Trisana ein Netzwerk mitbenutzt.
Der ISP, also der Internet Service Provider, stellt dir eine bestimmte Bandbreite zur Verfügung,
die du dir mit allen Nutzern in deinem Netzwerk teilen musst.
Wenn nun ein unbekannter Dritter hinzukommt, geht das zu Kosten deiner Verbindung.
Insbesondere Spyware, die in regelmäßigen Abständen große Datenmengen über das Internet
an den Angreifer sendet, lässt sich über Anomalien im Netzwerkverkehr feststellen.
Eine erste Anlaufstelle ist z.B. der ISP, der dir gegebenenfalls eine Warnung geben kann,
weil wie so oft entweder die Warnung gestört ist oder Bauarbeiten bei denen enttäuscht
sind, weder Warnung noch Entwarnung geben, die plicken ja bei ihrem eigenen Scheiß nicht
durch.
Max, was sagst du zum neuen Edge Browser?
Ich finde es komplett überflüssig, aber man kann ihn verwenden.
Router.
Der Router.
Ich persönlich bin ja auch eher für Router als Aussprache, aber gerade unsere Cisco Netzwerkleute,
die bestehen auf Router.
Abweichungen festmachen kannst, ob die Rechnung mit deinem Verbrauch tatsächlich aufgeht.
Spätestens dann, wenn du keinen Zugriff mehr auf dein Account hast, solltest du dich unbedingt
an den Webseitenbetreiber wenden.
Denn wenn du dir sicher bist, ein richtiges Passwort eingegeben zu haben und dennoch nicht
reinkommst, dann wurde dein Account vermutlich von einem anderen übernommen und das Passwort
geändert.
Ob du nun auf Passwort vergessen klicken und somit deinerseits den Angreifer durch die
Vergabe eines neuen Passworts aussperren solltest, ist fraglich, denn vermutlich hat der Hacker
schon daran gedacht und die Fallback-E-Mail-Adresse gegen seine getauscht.
Dann wird nur der Hacker darüber benachrichtigt, dass du gerade versucht hast, dein Account
zurückzuklauen.
Wenn es ganz schlecht läuft und du überall dasselbe Passwort verwendest, dann hat der
Hacker vielleicht sogar auch den entsprechenden E-Mail-Account übernommen.
Deshalb gilt, wähle sichere Passwörter und am besten für jeden Online-Dienst ein anderes.
Und zwei Fakte Online-Infizierung.
Ein Video zu sicheren Passwörtern, Link unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Auch ein Gang zu den zuständigen Ermittlungsbehörden schadet nicht.
Selbst dann, wenn ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen den Täter erfolglos erscheint, solltest
du wenigstens in der Statistik als ungelöster Fall oder ähnliches auftauchen und politisch
Druck auszuüben, der im Optimalfall zu einer besseren Ausstattung und Ausbildung der Ermittler
führt.
Was?
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen.
Das hab ich, das hab ich.
Das letzte hab ich nicht kapiert.
Passwörtern, Link unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Auch ein Gang zu den zuständigen Ermittlungsbehörden schadet nicht.
Selbst dann, wenn ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen den Täter erfolglos erscheint, solltest
du wenigstens in der Statistik als ungelöster Fall oder ähnliches auftauchen.
Und politisch Druck auszuüben, der im Optimalfall zu einer besseren Ausstattung und Ausbildung
der Ermittler führt.
Da hat er Recht.
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen.
Wird nicht passieren, weil Internet, Infrastruktur, Kram, Deutschland ist halt...
Ja.
Aber Tu-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Was haben wir sonst hier noch zu bieten?
Strangest Computer Designs, noch ein bisschen Battlefield, The Last of Us, zwei Tests,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das gucken will.
So, RTX 3080, 3090, ein Lego Betonmischer, warum auch immer.
Und das Video, wo ich letztens schon mal gesagt habe, dass ich das nicht schlecht fand, weil
er das einfach ziemlich neutral präsentiert.
Der Sebaro ist wach, nice, GG, das Lego Video, das Lego Video können wir noch gucken.
Die Lego Videos sind, das ist so die typische Sorte von Videos, wo ich mir denke, Alter,
warum?
Aber trotzdem geil.
Der Betonmischer mit einer, ist das eine, das ist einfach eine Plastikflasche, oder?
Ja.
Oh, jetzt wird angedockt.
Jetzt würde ich mal an der Stelle vor der Katze aufdenken.
Eine Tabletsteuerung, richtig big brain.
Was eine geile Konstruktion, zwar irgendwie wieder absolut sinnlos, aber ich mag die Videos.
Guck mal, sogar mit, sogar mit rückwärts leuchten oder sowas.
Guck mal, man kann das sogar schütteln.
Ah, okay, dann habe ich es jetzt falsch eingeschätzt, ich dachte nämlich, ich dachte, dass da drüber
das Wasser reinkommt, über den Schlauch, weil hier rutscht das ja gar nicht mehr, danach.
Ob da jetzt was sinnvolles rauskommt?
Muss man das nicht normalerweise noch ein bisschen rühren dabei?
Also rühren die Mischmaschinen das nicht noch ein bisschen?
Excellent Baustelle.
Oh, guck mal, das kann sogar sauber machen.
Cool, die Dinger gucke ich mir immer gerne an.
Komplett sinnlos, aber trotzdem irgendwie nice.
Wie lange sind wir eigentlich schon am Start?
Vor Stunden?
Ja, sowas sieht ja absolut langweilig aus.
Das bestimmt Alienware oder irgendeinen Vorgänger von Alienware, die Dinger sehen ja heute immer
noch so aus.
Napster?
Gibt es das noch?
Also das ursprüngliche Napster gibt es nicht mehr, aber gibt es Napster an sich noch?
Das einzige was da übrig geblieben ist, ist das Logo, oder?
Was?
Ja, das einzige was übrig geblieben ist, ist wohl echt das Logo noch.
Moment, ist das ein Hocker?
Ist das ein Hocker?
Sieht aus wie ein Hocker.
Guck mal, es lacht, es lacht.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist ein Hocker, der lacht.
Der freut sich.
Ja, das erste woran ich gedacht habe, sieht aus wie ein Klo.
Es sieht auch übelst hässlich aus.
Illuminati Leute!
Das geht so ein bisschen als Weihnachtsbeleuchtung vielleicht durch.
Das ist toll, wirklich toll, wie viel esco ist.
Bizarre follow-up to the 1998 g3 the core components were packed into its bulbous base
Whereas the lcd protruded from the top and swung around on a metal arm like a desk lamp
While it was lauded for its elegant display it was criticized apple fan fitness apple fans finden es wahrscheinlich trotzdem geil
For its relatively low power and high cost and discontinued less than two years later
the chumby industries chumby
After a short public testing
Oh, guck mal da
The chumby was released as a portable computer designed to be thorough
Das ist ein Hocker oder ist ein Lautsprecher
Customized by its owner it featured a three and a half inch lcd touch screen a
350 megahertz arm chipset came wrapped in padded leather and ran a version of linux that was customizable by installing software widgets
You could turn it into a dedicated newsreader dedicated music player
Linux basis was spun off into the non portable sony dash in 2010 chumby devices ceased production two years later with the
servers shutting down in 2013
The IBM little tykes young explorer although originally announced in 1998
Das ist so ein ding weil ich mir gut vorstellen kann dass es in irgendeiner spielecke
Beim ica oder bei irgendeinem möbelhaus oder sonst worum steht
Wo die eltern die kinder abstellen können dass sie in ruhe einkaufen gehen
Die early 2000s that ibm's young explorer computer systems started showing up everywhere kids happen to be schools daycares airports restaurants dentist offices you name it the hardware inside was a
Stand um a la pizzeria center pc, but it was housed in a child-friendly plastic desk
Manufactured by rubbermaid and sold under their little tykes brand it was quite a success even though they sold for upwards of
$2,500
the oq o model o2
This is a time when this is windows 7 this is windows 7 this must relativ relativ neu sein
Na gut 2000 personal computer or you mpc was poised to take the world by storm
Wister an oq o ja er hat recht das ist wister das ist wister
Daher was model o2 was a much lauded example starting at $1,500
Der korona man ist by none other than bill gates in 2007 and featured a fully functional windows vista computer
Es läuft sogar minecraft drauf dann verstehe ich ja gar nicht dass ich das nicht verkauft hat small enough to fit in your pocket
However, the battery life was pretty abysmal and the blackberry like keyboard was lacking besides that netbook computers
Vor allem wozu?
Der anwendungszweck erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht wozu brauche ich ein vollständiges wister
Auf so einem mini bildschirm mit kaum akku laufzeit in der scheiß tastatur
About the takeoff by 2010 the company had gone bankrupt
three comms audrey
internet appliances were all the rage around the turn of the century and three comms ergo audrey from
2000 was one of the more high-profile ones named after it's all purpose was to connect to the internet and perform basic
Computing tasks using its qa. Ob das schon java script unterstützt
Next based operating system
Despite notable first year sales it died a swift death during the dot-com crash of 2001 and due to an influx of cheap
liquidated units it became rather popular among hardware hacking enthusiasts in the following years
lenovo's thinkpad w700 ds
What's better than a computer with a built-in display? Das kenne ich
Das kenne ich
Ich glaube wir hatten sogar früher sowas auf der arbeit
Sowas habe ich glaube ich mal gesehen bei uns
Weil wir hatten nur wir hatten nur ibm thinkpads damals
Glauben sowas hatten wir
Okay, 11 pounds to kilogram
Na ein hat fünf kilo okay, das ist ordentlich für notebook
And the battery lasted maybe two hours on a good day
the disney dreamdesk pc
Never missing a chance to slap mouse ears on something the walt disney company released the dream desk computer in 2004
Bist ja was das sieht aus wie ein luddkolben
Und haben andere von abgesehen wenn es kein luddkolben ist frage ich mich gerade was ist es dann
Walt disney company released the dream desk computer in 2004
Manifaktured by electronics giant median it featured a mickey mouse display with built-in speakers a keyboard with a built-in drawing tablet pen
And a case with a door that slides over the cables in the back to keep kids away from the important stuff
Oddly enough these silly design was the main issue that prevented it from selling very well along with the fact that for
$900 you could get something far more powerful. Yeah, yeah
the
Imagine yet another company taking a shot at making media center pcs interesting
Maniwals idea was to go. Man muss ja sagen das sieht zumindest schon mal irgendwie ganz hübsch aus
With the I imagine imagine I star imagine stupid name some thought the case design was elegant and even beautiful
Others found it looked more like a bomb. Ich finde es sieht ganz gut aus
Whatever your stance it was priced between two thousand and three
boasting a built-in touch screen speakers and hard drive
Aber guck mal schon hdmi
You could use it as a portable media player in addition to a windows vista media center pc on your tv
But with no batteries and that lofty price tag its appeal was understandably limited
And that's all for this particular video, and if you enjoyed this why not check out some of my others
I've got a video on some bizarre
So wir hätten jetzt noch zu bieten den last of us 2 test ich glaube den gucke ich nicht
Ich glaube den will ich nicht gucken
Nur für den fall der fälle dass man doch was drinnen verraten kriegt
Snipe battlefield kommen wir können auch eine runde battlefield gucken oder oder was zu einem rtx 3090 leak
Leckeres taco rezept
Excellent taco gehen immer tacos gehen immer
Wobei ich mir eher burrito menüs hole für unsere mexikaner einfach weil er mehr dran ist
Ein eigenbau chiller was ist denn ein chiller
Ein kühler
Was ist ein chiller ein kühler
Das ist der Typ der sein Ofen übertaktet hat, das hatten wir auch mal geguckt.
Shooter mit guter Story Desintegration
Wir kommen uns mal das GTX League an.
Das ist Werbung.
Ach, das ganze League Zeug ist doch zum größten Teil heute eh geplant.
Mir kann keiner erzählen, dass die jährlichen Battlefield, Call of Duty, X, Y und sonst
was, Hardware, irgendwas Leaks, dass sie nicht im Interesse der Hersteller sind zum größten
Teil.
Zum größten Teil, ja.
Manchmal, manchmal nicht, gerade bei Apple kommt manchmal was raus, wo ich mir denke,
das wollen die eher nicht.
Aber die meisten Leaks, die sind doch mittlerweile Hersteller gefaked.
Was geht es denn los mit dem Leak?
Ja.
Oh guck mal, das ist sogar auf Deutsch, am neunten Juni, so sieht es also aus, sieht
anders aus, sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Lautsprecher, Lautsprecher mit nur einem Lautsprecher,
also.
Na klar, was sonst, ok ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich glaube das Video ist langweilig,
ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich glaube das Video
ist langweilig, ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich glaube das Video ist langweilig, ich glaube
Sollte 80 30 80 die rausbringen dass ich mir endlich neun rechner kaufen kann
Ich gucke noch ne runde battlefield fertig oder wollen wir das review gucken sagt mir gar nix
Desintegration
Lieber so als dieses unsägliche interview format
Ne ne dann dann doch nicht das heißt aber nicht automatisch dass das spiel einfach ist besonders in den letzten beiden der vier auswählbaren spiele
Das sieht doof aus das sieht nicht aus wie ein game was mir gefällt
Ich war es nicht. Guck uns lieber das taco rezept an. Wir gucken uns Battlefield an
Erst mal erst mal den dude rausschneiden auch voll den arsch gesniped
Hallo und willkommen zu
Neuen pc du hast doch schon an 8700k ja das ist ja das problem warum sich nicht lohnt neuen pc zu kaufen
Deswegen warte ich auf 4.950 x und 30 80 ti dann lohnt es sich halbwegs neuen pc zu kaufen
Nicht getroffen
Der ist absichtlich reingeflohen oder
Was sagst du eigentlich so ps5
Sieht aus wie ne fritzbox mit zwei weißen plättern an die seite gepappt
Ansonsten gab es ja auf dem event jetzt nicht so viel tolles worüber man sich auslassen kann
Also wahnsinnig jetzt irgendwie vom zocken
Gehauen hat es mir nicht flopp solche kills finde ich immer geil dass und das ist was das kriegst nur in battlefields geboten sowas
Schon wieder die typen wie oft will er wie oft will er diese clips noch zeigen die auf golden railway auf diesem auf dem stromast sitzen
Die auf dem stromast sitzen
Wie oft will er diese clips noch zeigen die auf golden railway auf diesem auf dem stromast sitzen
Das hat er jetzt schon die letzten drei wochen drin gehabt
Bam die helis fliegen da absichtlich rein glaube manchmal
Aber zwei clips von lackey die sich ein bisschen auf die battlefields auftritt. Dieser bf3 agressiven sniping clip ist absolut wunderschön
Hatten wir das nicht eben schon
Die eben war aber ein ähnlicher clip
Und das ist jetzt wieder ein clip von lackey die sich ein bisschen auf die battlefields auftritt. Das ist jetzt wieder ein clip von lackey die sich ein bisschen auf die battlefields auftritt.
Grancamper sind massive residence leaper die gegner ich kriege anfälle
Love it or hate it is something that you sometimes do need to utilize while playing tdm on battlefield 3 noshark canals
And then he goes on a massive kill streak with this
Sind das sind das steam noobs sind das steam noobs gibt's gibt's in battlefield jetzt steam noobs
Stimmt das gerücht eigentlich von einem battlefield 3 remake ja
confirmed
Ich habe es gesagt jetzt bei mir habe das zuerst gehört
Ich konfirme dass es stimmt
Was weiß ich ob das stimmt keine ahnung
Vor soll ich das wissen nein keine ahnung ob das stimmt ich finde es logisch
Ich finde es klingt ich finde es klingt logisch dass sie das machen
Weil sie was zur überbrückung von battlefield 5 zu battlefield 6 brauchen
Wir müssen übrigens mal gleich auf battle log gucken wie die server aussehen
Battlefield 4 und wir schauen uns an ein game of rush auf zavod
Es ist natürlich die
Die objekte
Die gehen auch die gehen wenn ich die wachhochkorps wie sie reinrennen
Dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt dutt
Und
Das ist demavan peak edge 1 demavan peak clip
Die
Die versuchen in die ganze zeit zur rpg aber mich, aber zu zu ppega aim sind
Bester rush map okay eine der besten rush maps beste rush map kann man sich darüber streiten was das jetzt wirklich ist
Für mich ist er immer noch
Port Walters ist auf jeden Fall ganz weit vorne, aber mal vom Battlefield 3 ausgesehen ist das auf jeden Fall eine der besten Rushmaps
Das commentary ist von ihm immer das gleiche
Get schreckt
So hat ist nächstes battlefield 4 operation mortar und ein incredible die map habe ich glaube ich
Boah
Keine ahnung ob ich die gespielt habe
Wahrscheinlich aber ich kann mir niemand dran erinnern
das war auf jeden fall eine dlc map
Nein das ist nicht wake island sieht nur so ähnlich aus
Playing on scrap metal battlefield 3 with the m27 and c4 he manages to get himself banned this is first time
You'll see somebody banned from a closed quarters server
3 bestills
Watch as he dominates lmg legit
Wir sind da rein rennen zivier das ja geil die gegner
So muss das sein
liegt
a
nice aws clip sent in from dusty playing on operation outbreak the community map which is a really cool feature that does
Implemented back in the bf4 days letting the community build a map together and have lots of inputs when it was being made
This is an epic clip as he gets on top of the rocks here and just mows the enemy players down
Was ist das für eine waffe in schiener waffe oder ne was ist denn das aws
Sieht aus wie eine soltreife mit problemagazin DLC waffe
Schwemrischer
Und dieser hier ist ein schönes objektives Spiel.
Er rutscht in Richtung der Carparksektion des Maps hier.
Ihr seht, dass er hier einen Tiefschuss auf einen Eder hat...
Doch nicht.
Ich war noch ein bisschen pech am Anfang.
Er hat ein paar Tiefschüsse auf seinem Weg über den Carpark.
Er kommt in den Carpark und dann klärt er ihn aus,
von allen anderen Gegnern.
G18, jawoll. Mit der G18 geht halt was.
Da ist einer gespawnt.
Der ist einfach zu blöd, das zu checken,
dass sein Team-Mate gerade gekillt wurde von der Treppe aus.
Massive.
Monarch-S Gegner.
Was macht der da?
Auf die Erde gucken in der Ecke.
Die Bodentexture hier ist aber besonders crisp.
Da werden sie gereckt.
Aber heftig.
Das könnten echt Bots sein, ja.
Warum hat der Chet in Battlefield eigentlich keine Raketen?
Boah, hat der Ounty aber schon krass weg.
Und keiner, keiner...
Schießt ihn ab.
Keiner stingert ihn runter.
Der geht aber gut ab.
Ich kann es nicht würdigen, weil ich kein Chet-Pilot bin
und keine Ahnung, wie schwer das ist.
Oh.
AfK-Gegner.
Ja, die sind wirklich clueless.
Guckt euch an, der Bot.
Da steht er einfach und guckt in eine Richtung.
Oh, Kassaden.
GLHF.
In your face.
Legehähne.
Wie, keine Legehähne?
Ach doch, der wollte Legehähne machen, aber ist wieder eingestiegen in den Panzer.
Haha, der Gegner.
Oh guck mal, da steht ein Panzer.
Was mach ich?
Ich setz mich direkt vors Rohr und lass mich abschießen.
Aber Panzerfahren im Battlefield hat Bock gemacht.
Gerade in Battlefield 3.
Guckt euch an.
Easy Legehähne win.
Und er wollte noch entschärfen, obwohl das M-Com schon kaputt ist.
Hat aber Glück, dass er gereppt wird.
Wie dunkel.
Er wollte die M-Com reparieren, das wäre richtig big brain, wenn das ging.
Wut, wut.
Oh, da wurde um die Ecke gehitted.
Also ich kann mich an keinen Battlefield erinnern, wo man M-Com reparieren konnte.
Was ist eigentlich deine Lieblingsklasse im Battlefield?
Im Battlefield 3 eindeutig Medic, das war das Beste am ganzen Game.
Du hattest die besten Waffen, konntest dich heilen, also bessere Kombi gab's eigentlich gar nicht.
Am besten noch mit extra Ammo dabei.
Bad Company 2, das einzige Game, wo ich eigentlich gerne Sniper gespielt hab.
Aber auch nur, weil es halt diese Kombination aus Motion Sensor plus One-Hit Nahkampf Sniper war.
Bad Company 2, das einzige Game, wo ich richtig gerne Sniper gespielt hab.
Also nicht Sniper in Form von Rumliegen, sondern reinlaufen, Motion Sensor und alles One-Hitten.
Wollen wir jetzt eigentlich mal alle zusammen im Stream Battlefield spielen?
Weiß nicht, vielleicht installier ich mir nachher Bad Company 2, mal gucken.
Ansonsten hab ich in Bad Company 2 auch Medic sehr gerne gespielt mit den LMGs.
Gerade M60 mit ACOG war so OP, das war so eine automatische Sniper quasi schon.
Bad Company 2 dürfte auf fast allem laufen.
Oh, wie sie sich wieder alle wegspringen lassen.
Die Legehänne ist am Start. Ach nee, die Entschärfungshänne ist am Start.
Was ist das Gegenteil von der Legehänne, Leute? Entschärfungshänne passt nicht.
Die Legehänne plantet das M-Com und was macht, was ist Entschärfen?
Entlegehänne, das klingt aber noch bescheuerder.
Die hat er schön gebashed.
Die Gegner sind wieder richtig dämlich.
Alter, sind die doof.
Ja, nice. Leute, sind wir wach?
Ich glaub, wir sind wach, weil ich muss mal aufs Klo und ich hab Hunger.
Das Lego-Video angucken. Der Heu, was ist denn ein Bailer? Heu-Roller oder sowas?
Bad Company 2 Highlight. Ich glaube, sowas gibt es aktuell nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, sowas gibt es aktuell nicht mehr. Schauen wir mal, this year.
Okay.
Das Konsole? Die Auflösung ist so gering. Ist das Konsole? Das sieht aus wie Xbox.
Schau dir seltene Nachladeanimationen an. Mach ich.
Wir sind mal wieder bei Absolute Brainhead Gegnern angelangt. Das ist Xbox, oder?
Das ist PC? Ja, stimmt. Die Schriftgröße müsste PC sein, aber das Foff, ey.
Ist das ein Messer-Montage?
What the fuck? Ja, das ist irgendein Messer-Montage.
Man konnte übrigens Bad Company 2 auch um die Ecke messern.
Ja, das hat man gerade gesehen. Okay, das sind keine Highlights. Der messert einfach Leute und schneidet es dann zusammen.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn. Trickstabber 360 Quick Quickstep.
Sicher, dass es PC ist. So wie der Rom eiert, ist das doch eher Konsole, oder?
Aber 1, 2, 3, das muss PC sein.
Stimmt, kann man in PC 2 das Foff ändern?
90 Foff, ja, das muss man, muss ich dann machen.
Also was soll ich mal angucken? Seltene Nachladeanimationen.
Welches Video davon? Weiß gar nicht, wer es geschrieben hat.
All Rare Secret Reload Animations.
Battlefield Hardline?
Die Auflösung ist mega mies.
Hardline habe ich so wenig gespielt, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Erstmal weg, RPGen.
Wie sind diese Nachladeanimationen aufgetreten? Random oder musste man da irgendwas drücken?
Das ist ja geil, die Nachladeanimation ist ja genial.
Die ist übelst geil.
Die ist aber mies animiert.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, wo die dritte Hand dann so reinkommt und ihm das Magazin gibt.
Den kann ich noch.
Alter reg dich mal ab.
Warum flippt der so aus?
Da waren schon ein paar coole Sachen bei Every Secret Reload.
Das ist aber schlecht bewertet.
Das haben wir schon alles gesehen.
Achso. Na gut.
Hatten die auch sowas in Battlefield 1 drin? Ich habe Battlefield 1 gar nicht gespielt außer Beta.
Was war da dran jetzt? Secret? Sieht doch ganz normal aus.
Gut, das...
Das ist ein übelst langweiliges Video.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt die LEGO Heupresse noch zum Schluss an.
Ah, yes, Heupresse. Ich habe schon immer eine Heupresse aus LEGO gebraucht für meinen Garten.
Ob das da hinten auch ein LEGO Haus war?
Noch fehlt eben das Heu. Ah, da ist das Heu. Golfplatz.
Also so wirklich, wenn man hinter das Ding guckt, so wirklich gründlich ist es nicht. Guck mal dahinter.
Der hat aufgeräumt. Der hat dahinter aufgeräumt. Der hat definitiv dahinter aufgeräumt. Am Anfang hat man nämlich gesehen, dass das bei weitem nicht alles aufgepickt wurde.
Ja, hier, guck mal.
Aber irgendwie ist es mal wieder richtig geil, was er da gebaut hat. Guck mal, der kann sogar das Ding einrollen.
Ist den langweilig und wahrscheinlich, aber ist trotzdem eine geile Idee.
Exzellent. Guck mal, der kann sogar aufnehmen.
Horgerz.
Big Brain Machine hier.
Ja, sehr schön.
Wunderbar. Leute, ich muss mal unbedingt aufs Klo und ich hab echt Hunger langsam.
War schön, dass so viele Leute wieder mit am Start waren.
Das war's für heute. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.